आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ
लेट मी चेक वंस गाइस
ओके मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए आप सभी इफ आई
एम लाइव ऑडिबल विजिबल
ऑडियो वीडियो बिल्कुल सही है बता दीजिए
फटाफट बता दीजिए एक बार जल्दी से इफ
एवरीथिंग इज सुपर फाइन
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस इफ एवरीथिंग
इज सुपर फाइन ऑडियो ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ
एकदम मस्त है। बताइए फटाफट जल्दी से ताकि
हम स्टार्ट करें। गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते टू
एवरीबॉडी। काफी दिनों के बाद हम वापस से
मिल रहे हैं एसओसी के इस क्लास के अंदर।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
आई [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एम गुड। आई
एम गुड। आई एम गुड। हाउ आर यू? मैं बढ़िया
हूं। आप बताइए आप कैसे हैं?
ओके
ओके लेट्स स्टार्ट। तो आज की क्लास को हम
स्टार्ट तो करते हैं। वी विल बी
स्टार्टिंग टुडे सेशन। जस्ट अ सेकंड। जस्ट
एक सेकंड रुक जाइए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
काफी लोग आ चुके हैं यहां पे ऑलरेडी। जो
भी आते हैं एक लाइक ठोकते जाना ताकि पता
चले
कि [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आपको मजा आ
रहा है कि नहीं आ रहा है। आपको मजा आना
चाहिए। दैट्स द मेन पर्पस। मजा आपको आ रहा
है तो पर्पस जो है वो फुलफिल्ड है।
जस्ट अ सेकंड।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हां जी।
चलिए। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सो आज की
क्लास हम स्टार्ट तो करते हैं बट उसके
पहले कुछ चीजें हैं जो आपको जाननी है आपको
उसके बारे में। अब क्योंकि इस क्लास के
लिए वह काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है। उस पे हम आते
हैं। बस सबसे पहले एक दो चीजें हैं जो
आपको करनी होती है।
जब भी आप क्लास देखना शुरू करते हैं जब भी
आप वीडियोस देखना स्टार्ट करते हैं तो
किसी भी जैसे हमारे YouTube चैनल पे आ
जाइएगा। डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल
पे। ठीक है? इस वाले पे आप डेफ्रोनिक सर्च
कर सकते हैं YouTube पे। लाइव सेक्शन पे
जाइएगा। यहां पे किसी भी एसओसी की पहले
प्रीवियस वीडियो को आप ओपन कर लीजिएगा
यहां पे। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक
है? जब आप ओपन कर लोगे तो यहां पर जो इस
वीडियो का डिस्क्रिप्शन है
[संगीत]
नाउ एवरीथिंग इज गुड राइट सब कुछ सही है
अब परफेक्ट
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
तो जैसे किसी भी किसी भी एसओसी के वीडियो
के डिस्क्रिप्शन में से दोनों लिंक्स को
यहां पे डिस्क्रिप्शन में लिंक्स है कर
लीजिएगा यहां पे पहला जो आपको लिंक होगा
ये होगा हमारे WhatsApp चैनल का आप इसको
जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा हमारे WhatsApp चैनल
को बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट कोई पैसा नहीं
देना को 13,000 लोग यहां हमसे जुड़े हैं
अभी तक। जितनी भी हमारे साइट से ओवरऑल
किसी भी तरह की अपडेट्स होती है, वह सबसे
पहले चैनल पे आती है। इस चैनल पे एक ग्रुप
होगा जो कि एसओसी स्पेसिफिक ग्रुप है। इस
सीरीज के लिए स्पेशली है। जो भी नोट्स,
रिसोर्सेज या जो भी अपडेट्स,
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हमारे साइड से इस पर्टिकुलर
ट्रेनिंग फ्री जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग की होती
है वो इसी ग्रुप में आती है। सबसे पहले तो
इसको जरूर जॉइ कर लीजिएगा। सभी लोग जॉइ कर
लीजिएगा इसको। ठीक है? ये दो चीजें करने
के बाद आप Lindin पे मुझे यहां पे आके
फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मुझसे कनेक्ट कर सकते
हैं। मुझसे जुड़ सकते हैं। यहां पे आपको
Lindin की मेरी प्रोफाइल दिख जाएगी यहां
पे। साथ ही में आप Lindin पे जब आप
डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्च करेंगे Lindin पे जाके तो
हमारी डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
Lindin पेज आपको कंपनी का पेज देखने को
मिलेगा। इसको आप जरूर फॉलो कीजिएगा। हमारी
कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग बहुत सारी अपडेट्स
एंड अलग-अलग तरह की इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें
आपको इस पेज पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देखने को मिल
जाती है। लगभग 22,000 लोग यहां पे हमसे
जुड़े हैं। तो इसको आके फॉलो कर लीजिएगा।
यह हमारी डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी Instagram पेज
है। जहां पे आपको इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल साइबर
सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड कंटेंट्स जो है वो
रील्स पोस्ट्स के थ्रू आपको मिल जाते हैं।
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग। जैसे कि अभी आप देख रहे
होंगे लास्ट कुछ कंटेंट्स की बात करें तो
10 साइबर सिक्योरिटी प्रोजेक्ट्स आइडियाज
जो है आप इसमें इस रील को देख सकते हैं।
इस पोस्ट को देख सकते हैं। फ्री साइबर
सिक्योरिटी सर्टिफिकेशंस के बारे में देख
सकते हैं। डार्क वेफेरो फोरम्स को आप देख
सकते हैं। यहां पे सेशन हाईजेकिंग का एक
डिकोडिंग वनेबिलिटी सीरीज को देख सकते
हैं। फ्री एआई टूल्स, कॉपी फेल वनेबिलिटी,
टॉप सीवी, टॉप गीटब रेपोज़िटरी बहुत सारी
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मिलेंगी। तो इसको जरूर
आके फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यहां पे 500 से भी
ज्यादा हमारे फॉलोअर्स हैं जो हमें फॉलो
करते हैं कंटेंट्स के लिए उनको अच्छे
कंटेंट्स यहां पे हम डिलीवर करते हैं। यह
मेरी पर्सनल लिंकन प्रोफाइल Instagram
प्रोफाइल हैडल लिटेशन हैकर के साथ। आप
इसको आके फॉलो करके मेरे साथ पर्सनली
कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं। यह हमारा एक्स का पेज
है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी का। यू कैन कम एंड
फॉलो दिस पेज एज वेल। यह हमारी वेबसाइट
है। आप इसको आके विजिट कर सकते हैं।
बुकमार्क कर सकते हैं इस वेबसाइट को। यहां
पे ये हमारा कांटेक्ट नंबर है जहां पे आप
हमसे WhatsApp पे किसी भी तरह की क्वेरी
क्वेश्चंस कर सकते हैं। एकडमी पे जाके आप
हमारे कोर्सर्सेस जो है वो एक्सप्लोर कर
सकते हैं। साथ ही में एंड यहां पे यह
हमारा डीसीजीएसपी कोर्स है जो कि काफी
काफी ज्यादा एक मोस्ट डिमांडेड एंड सबसे
ज्यादा जो है एनरोल्ड कोर्स आप बोल सकते
हैं एंड काफी ज्यादा पॉपुलर कोर्स बोल
सकते हैं जो बिगिनर्स के बीच में है।
डीसीजीएसपी ये टू मंथ्स का प्री रिकॉर्डेड
कोर्स है। फिलहाल के लिए यह वैसे टू 2500
का यह कोर्स आपको मिलता है। फिलहाल एक ऑफर
चल रहा है जो कि आज रात को 12:00 बजे तक
है। 11:59 PM तक आप वो ऑफर का लुत्फ उठा
सकते हैं। बेसिकली 1000 का डिस्काउंट है
यहां पे। इंडिया 1000 कूपन कोड यूज़ कर
लीजिएगा। या अगर किसी को लेना हो तो
इंडिया 1000 कूपन कोड यहां पे आप इंडिया
1000 ऐसे कूपन कोड यूज़ करेंगे आप। तो आपको
वो डिस्काउंट जो है वो मिलके ये 1500 की
हो जाती है। तो अभी आज रात तक की ऑफर है
तो प्लीज लेना हो तो आप इस पे आके ले सकते
हैं। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] उसके
बाद ये सारी चीजें तो चलिए हो गई है। अब
आज की जो क्लास है उसको स्टार्ट तो करेंगे
बट उसके पहले मेरे पास कुछ है जो मैं आपको
आज की क्लास के लिए बताना चाहता हूं।
क्योंकि आज की जो क्लास है वो हम
वायरशार्क के ऊपर पढ़ने वाले हैं। ठीक है?
हम वायरशार्क के बारे में जानने वाले हैं।
सो बेसिकली वी विल बी नोइंग व्हाट इज वाय
शार्क? व्हाई दिस टूल इज रियली रियली वेरी
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग एंडेंट फॉर यू ऑल एंड एज
एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट या एज अ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट आल्सो आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट भी हैं साइबर
सिक्योरिटी डोमेन में भी हैं किसी और
डोमेन में भी हैं मतलब नेटवर्क
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर भी हैं सब कुछ तो आप वाशक
टूल को यूज़ करेंगे ही करेंगे एज एन
एसोसिएलिस्ट एज अ नेटवर्क एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
या एज अ साइबर सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट यू आर
गोइंग टू यूज़ द वाशक टूल उसके बिना आप
बहुत सारी चीजें नहीं कर पाते हैं तो वाशक
टूल इज़ देयर क्योंकि ये एक ऐसा टूल है जो
कि एक पैकेट एनाल एनालाइजर आप इसको बोल
सकते हैं। नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक एनालाइजर,
नेटवर्क डेटा एनालाइजर, नेटवर्क पैकेट
एनालाइजर, आईपी पैकेट एनालाइजर नेटवर्क के
पैकेट्स को आप एनालाइज करते हैं इस टूल के
अंदर में। ठीक है? सिंपल नेटवर्क के
ट्रैफिक्स को एनालाइज करते हैं। एनालाइज
करके आप अलग-अलग तरह के पैरामीटर्स होते
हैं। अलग-अलग तरह के फिल्टर्स होते हैं इस
टूल के अंदर में। उन फिल्टर्स का यूज करके
आप उससे डेटा निकालते हैं, डेटा फिल्टर
करते हैं और पढ़ते हैं कि एग्जैक्टली
नेटवर्क में जो ट्रांसमिशंस हुई हैं, जैसे
दो कंप्यूटर हैं। अगर दो कंप्यूटर आपस में
बात कर रहे हैं। ठीक है? तो उन दोनों के
बीच में डेटा का ट्रांसमिशन होता है। एक
कंप्यूटर दूसरे को डेटा भेजेगा दूसरे
दूसरा जो है फिर तीसरे को भेजता है। तीसरा
चौथे को भेजता है। ऐसे भेजता है। दो
कंप्यूटर का बात करें तो एक दूसरे को डेटा
भेजते हैं। एक सेंडर होता है, एक रिसीवर
होता है। फिर एक टाइम पे दूसरा जो रिसीवर
होता है वो सेंडर हो जाता है और पहला जो
सेंडर होता है वो रिसीवर बन जाता है।
राइट? इस तरीके से चीजें चलती रहती है। दो
कंप्यूटर के बीच में बात होती है। एक
क्लाइंट एक सर्वर की तरह एक्ट करता है और
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वहां पे थ्री
वे हैंडशक टीसीp थ्री वे हैंडशक जैसी
कांसेप्ट्स जो है यूज़ में आती है जो कि
कम्युनिकेशन एस्टैब्लिश करने के लिए लिया
जाता है। जब जैसे ही TCP थ्री वे हैंडशक
कंप्लीट हो जाती है तो दोनों जो क्लाइंट
सर्वर हैं वो एक दूसरे से बात करना शुरू
कर देते हैं। यानी डाटा ट्रांसफर करना
शुरू कर देते हैं। अब ये डेटा ट्रांसफर का
पूरा जो प्रोसेस है वो अगर आपने
टीसीपीआईपी ओएसआई मॉडल ये जो नेटवर्किंग
में पढ़ा होगा तो आपको आईडिया होगा। इसके
बारे में ऑलरेडी बताया भी गया है आपको
बहुत अच्छे से डिटेल में। तो इसके बारे
में आपको आईडिया ऑलरेडी होगी। बट अगर नहीं
है बाय चांस आईडिया। तो मैं आपको बताता
हूं वायर शार्क आपको मैं बहुत ही बेसिक
तरीके से पढ़ा दूंगा। बहुत अच्छे से समझा
भी दूंगा। सब कुछ आपको समझ में आ जाएगा।
बट नेटवर्किंग का नॉलेज होना एज एन एसओसी
एनालिस्ट एल1 आपके लिए काफी ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट होगा। अब इसकी नॉलेज कैसे आपको
लेनी है मैं आपको उसका भी आईडिया दे देता
हूं। जैसे अभी आप डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
YouTube चैनल पे चलेंगे। राइट? जस्ट गो टू
द डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल। यहां
पे
प्लेलिस्ट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
में आपको आना है। ठीक है? आप जैसे ही
प्लेलिस्ट में आते हैं तो यहां पे आप
थोड़ा सा यहां पे नीचे की तरफ स्क्रॉल
करेंगे। जरा सा नीचे की तरफ स्क्रॉल
करेंगे तो आपको एक प्लेलिस्ट मिलेगी
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी फ्री ट्रेनिंग। आप
इसको व्यू फुल कोर्स पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा।
तो इसके अंदर की जितनी भी वीडियोस वगैरह
हैं वो सब आपको देखने को यहां पे मिल
जाएंगे। अब इस प्लेलिस्ट में जो ये पूरी
प्लेलिस्ट है 13 वीडियो की है। ओनली 13
वीडियो है। बट एक जो क्लास है वो एवरेज 1
घंटे की ड्यूरेशन की यानी 13 घंटे का ये
पूरा का पूरा एक कोर्स है अपने आप में
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब इस कोर्स
के अंदर में आपका ओएसआई, टीसीपी मॉडल,
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का, नेटवर्किंग का
बहुत सारा कांसेप्ट बहुत ही अच्छे तरीके
से क्लियर हो जाएगा। आप में से कई लोगों
ने शायद यह वाला प्लेलिस्ट कंप्लीट किया।
आप में से कोई यहां पे है जिन्होंने इस
प्लेलिस्ट को ऑलरेडी कंप्लीट कर लिया है
या कंप्लीट कर रहे हैं या देखते हैं। ऐसा
कोई है क्या? आप में से प्लीज लेट मी नो।
प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ एनीवन हियर।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
थर्ड लेक्चर फोर्थ क्लास ओके स्टार्ट करी
है ऑन गोइंग ठीक है बहुत अच्छी बात है कुछ
लोगों ने स्टार्ट करी है अभी कुछ लोगों ने
देखा है कुछ लोगों ने अभी नहीं भी देखा
होगा बट आई रिकमेंड एंड आई रिक्वेस्ट
एवरीबडी हियर जो एसओसी सीरीज को फॉलो कर
रहे हैं इसके बिना आपका काम नहीं चलने
वाला है। याद रखिएगा आप यू कैन नॉट ब्लेम
मी फर्दर यू यू कैन नॉट ब्लेम मी इन
फ्यूचर कि सर आपने नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का
तो कुछ बताया ही नहीं था हमें किसकी भी
जरूरत होती है आपने तो इसके बारे में कुछ
बोला ही नहीं मुझे मैं हर एक चीज जो आपके
इस जर्नी के लिए इंपॉर्टेंट है इस जर्नी
को जो एल1 बनने का एक आपका प्रोफेशनल
जर्नी है जो एक जॉब रेडी जर्नी है जोज
चीजें रिक्वायर्ड हैं वो सब मैं आपको
बताता हूं मैक्सिमम चीजें तो मैं खुद आपको
सारी चीजें कवर करता हूं बट अब उसकी जो
थोड़ी बहुत प्रीरिक्वज़िट्स हैं। अब जैसे
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी तो हम पूरा नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी कवर नहीं कर सकते। बट स्टिल
मैंने नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी के बहुत सारी
चीजें ऑलरेडी सीरीज में कवर भी करी है।
अगर आपको [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नहीं पता तो मैं आपको बता भी दूंगा। अभी
फिर से अगेन आई विल लेट यू नो। बट नेटवर्क
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सिक्योरिटी के
लिए ये पूरी प्लेलिस्ट आपको कवर करनी है।
आपको अच्छे से सीरियसली आपको देखना है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इसको फॉलो करना
है। साथ ही में अगर आप एसओसी के भी
वीडियोस देखते हैं। मैं अगर प्लेलिस्ट में
जाऊं और हमारी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एसओसी की भी
प्लेलिस्ट को फुल मैं ओपन करूं तो जब आप
नीचे की तरफ आएंगे पहले की प्ले देखेंगे
यहां पे तो मैंने इसमें बताया हुआ है। आप
देखेंगे यहां पे मैंने डाटा पैकेट्स के
बारे में भी ऑलरेडी आपको बताया हुआ है।
थ्री वे हैंडशक के बारे में भी आपको
ऑलरेडी बताया है। आईपी सबनेट मैक एड्रेस
के बारे में भी बताया है। डीएनए स्पोर्ट्स
के बारे में बताया है। ओ ओएसआई एंड टीसीपी
आईपी मॉडल्स के बारे में भी पूरा डिटेल
में बताया है। तो ये बेसिकली ये एक
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है फॉर योर एसओसी जर्नी
एल1 जर्नी। तो आई रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबडी कि
प्लीज आप इसको सीरियसली लीजिएगा। आप सिर्फ
एसओसी का एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड यूज़ करना सीख
लेने से आप एसआईएम एक्सपर्ट बन जाने से
सिर्फ आप एसओसी एल1 नहीं बन जाएंगे। आप
एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट अपने आपको नहीं कह
सकते हैं कि अगर आपको एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड समझ
में आने लगा या एसआईएम कोई टूल आप लाइक
स्प्ल के यूज़ कर पा रहे हैं या या
व्हाटएवर या कोई सा भी एसआईएम प्लेटफार्म
आप यूज़ कर पा रहे हैं या या Sonar
प्लेटफार्म यूज़ तो आप एक एसओसी एल1 नहीं
कहलाएंगे। आपके कांसेप्ट्स और आपके हर एक
टॉपिक्स क्लियर होने चाहिए जो एसओसी एल1
के लिए इंपॉर्टेंट हो रहा है। तो आई
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबडी कि प्लीज आप ये
नेटवर्किंग के टॉपिक जो मैंने कराए हैं
उसको भी गो थ्रू कीजिए। साथ ही में यहां
पे
नेटवर्क [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सिक्योरिटी की ये प्लेलिस्ट को पूरा का
पूरा इसको कवर कर लीजिए। सिर्फ 13 वीडियोस
हैं। 13 घंटे की बात है। आपको ज्यादा टाइम
नहीं लग रहा है। प्लीज आई रिक्वेस्ट टू
कवर इट। साथ ही में इसके अलावा आप वीडियो
सेशन पे जब आप आएंगे तो यहां पे हमने एक
वीडियो अपलोड की थी कुछ दिन पहले। आपको
याद होगा तीन वीक यहां पे हो चुके हैं।
एथिकल हैकिंग फुल कोर्स। ठीक है? अब ये आप
सोच रहे होंगे एथिकल हैकिंग की कोर्स है।
बट ठीक है। एथिकल हैकिंग तो कोर्स है ही।
आपको पूरा नहीं देखना है। बट अगर आप
स्पेसिफिक कुछ देखना चाहते हैं इसके अंदर
में तो आप एसओसी के पर्सपेक्टिव से आप
देखेंगे [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां
टाइम स्टैंप्स दिया हुआ है। इसमें
नेटवर्किंग फंडामेंटल्स एक टाइम स्टैंप
है। इसको जरूर देख लीजिएगा। नेटवर्किंग
फंडामेंटल्स को और एक स्कैनिंग वाला टाइम
स्टैंप जो है आपका जिसमें एनमप वगैरह को
कवर किया गया है। एनमैप की चीजें बताई गई
है। इसको जरूर कवर कर लीजिएगा। ठीक है? ये
दो टाइम स्टैंप्स को यहां से सॉरी यहां से
दो एक नेटवर्किंग फंडामेंटल्स और स्कैनिंग
ये दो टाइम स्टैंप्स को कवर कीजिएगा। साथ
ही में यहां पे एक और वीडियो मैंने यहां
पे डलवाई है आप सबों के लिए क्योंकि
क्योंकि देखो कुछ चीजें ऐसी हैं जो
कनेक्टेड चीजें हैं तो हम उसकी वीडियो
लेकर आ रहे हैं आपके लिए। हम वीडियो के
फॉर्म में भी एक लंबी चौड़ी लगभग एक-ए
घंटे की वीडियोस आपके लिए ला रहे हैं। तो
एक वीडियो हमने डाली है एनमप ट्यूटोरियल
का। राइट? एनमप ट्यूटोरियल। इसमें कंप्लीट
लगभग 1 घंटे में पूरा एनमैप को कवर किया
है। बेसिक से लेके पूरा आगे तक सब कुछ। ये
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट रोल प्ले करने वाले हैं।
एज एन एसओसी एल1 एसओसी के एल1 से आप पोस्ट
पे हैं। तो वायर शार्क जैसी टूल काफी
हेल्प करेंगी। उसको समझना जरूरी है। एनमप
जैसी टूल आपकी हेल्प करेंगी। समझना समझना
जरूरी है नेटवर्किंग के कांसेप्ट्स को। IP
डीएनएस हो गया आपका मैक मैक एड्रेस हो
गया। एआरपी हो गई आपका। फिर डीएनएस के
अटैक्स वगैरह जो होते हैं वो सारी चीजें
हो गई। ओएसआई टीसीp मॉडल ये सब हो गया। ये
सब चीजें आपको समझनी जरूरी है। राइट? तो
ये सब चीज मैं आपको ऑलरेडी बता रहा हूं कि
कैसे-कैसे आपको क्या-क्या करना है। आपका
काम है फॉलो करना। आई रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी
टू प्लीज फॉलो। बाद में अब मत बोलिएगा कि
सर आपने ये चीज नहीं बताई। वो चीज नहीं
बताई। मैं सब चीजें बता रहा हूं। ये आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है कि आप एक-एक लाइन मेरी
सुनते हैं या नहीं सुनते हैं। ये स्किप
मार देते हैं कि अरे सर बहुत भाषण हो गई।
चलो अब स्किप मारो आगे बढ़ जाते हैं। ऐसा
नहीं है। एक-एक लाइन आप फॉलो करें। एक-एक
चीज फॉलो कर रहे हैं। डेफिनेटली यू विल
गेट टू लैंड अ जॉब इन एसओसी। आई बिलीव सो।
आई होप सो एंड आई एक्चुअली ट्रस्ट ऑन दिस
पर्टिकुलर थिंग कि अगर आप अपनी तरफ से
100% दे रहे हैं तो आपको एक अच्छा रिजल्ट
मिलने के चांसेस 99.9% है। बस इतना ही पता
है। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए ये सारी चीजें कर लेंगे। आज हम एसओसी
के इस क्लास के अंदर में एक बहुत ही
शानदार टॉपिक है। अ वायर शार्क उसको पढ़ने
वाले हैं। अब उसके स्टार्ट करेंगे। उसके
पहले मैं आपको बता दूं कि Windows पे
वायरशार्क को इंस्टॉल करना बहुत ही आसान
है। कुछ भी नहीं करना है। आपको जाना है
वायर शार्क डाउनलोड पेज पे Google कर लेनी
है। यहां पे जाना है। पहला लिंक आएगा
डाउनलोड वायरशार्क योर नेटवर्क एनालिसिस
टूल यहां पे आएगी। इसमें जब आप आएंगे तो
इसके स्टेबल रिलीजेस जो है वर्जन 4.6.8
है। यहां पे आपको अलग-अलग जो है इसके एंड
पॉइंट मतलब अलग-अलग आपके एंड पॉइंट्स के
लिए या मशीनंस के लिए आपको इंस्टॉलर मिल
जाएगा। जैसे Windows का आपको मिल जाएगा,
MacOS का मिल जाएगा, U12 का मिल जाएगा। ये
सारी चीजें मिल जाएंगी। राइट? ओल्ड
वर्जनंस भी आपको मिल जाते हैं। तो Windows
का आप यहां पे ये इंस्टॉलर वर्जन जो है
इसको डाउनलोड कर लीजिएगा। एक पोर्टेबल
वर्जन भी है बट आई वुड नॉट रेकमेंड दैट।
आप इंस्टॉल कीजिएगा एक Windows पाथ पे
ज्यादा बेटर रहेगा। तो यह जो इस पहला जो
है इसका इंस्टॉलर इसको डाउनलोड कर लीजिएगा
यहां पे। आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे डाउनलोड
जैसे ही क्लिक करेंगे ना डाउनलोड शुरू हो
जाएगा। ये देखो 94 MB के आसपास की है। बस
दैट्स इट। ईएक्सe फाइल है। मैं अभी कैंसिल
कर दे रहा हूं। ऑलरेडी मेरा इंस्टॉल्ड है।
यहां पे जब आप डाउनलोड करते हैं तो फिर
उसके बाद यह डोनेट का बोलते हैं। दिस इज़
नॉट कंपलसरी। आप इनको क्योंकि यह एक ओपन
सोर्स एंड फ्री प्रोजेक्ट है तो यह डोनेशन
आपसे ले डिमांड करते हैं। इफ यू वांट टू
डोनेट डेफिनेटली यू कैन गो अहेड एंड डोनेट
अदरवाइज सिंपल सा नो थैंक्स जस्ट डाउनलोड
करके आप इससे बाहर आ सकते हैं। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ये डाउनलोड
करके आप सिंपल डबल क्लिक किया नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट किया। आपका इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा।
उसमें आपको अलग-अलग तरह के फ़्टर्स
ड्राइवर्स इंस्टॉल करने का ऑप्शन आएगा। वो
ड्राइवर्स में इंस्टॉल आप कर लीजिएगा। दैट
वुड बी बेनिफिशियल एंड दैट्स इट आपका हो
जाएगा। उसके बाद जैसे ही आप इंस्टॉल वगैरह
कर लेंगे तो आप सिंपल वायर शार्क लिख के
इसको आप एक्सेस कर सकते हैं अपने Windows
के मशीन में। इस टूल को आप स्टार्ट कर
सकते हैं। जैसे ही टूल पहली बार आप
स्टार्ट करते हैं आपके जो भी अ
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
जितने भी नेटवर्क अपर्स हैं अ यूज़ हो रहे
हैं आपके सिस्टम के साथ वो सारे नेटवर्क
अपर्स यहां लिस्टेड हो जाएंगे। तो जो
करेंटली आप यूज़ कर रहे हैं उसको सेलेक्ट
करना है डबल क्लिक करके और आप उसको
स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं। तो जैसे मैं अभी
Wi-Fi यूज़ कर रहा हूं मेरा यह वाला। अभी
मेरा VMware वगैरह ये सब यूज़ नहीं हो रहा
है। इथर यूज़ नहीं हो रहा है। तो मैं Wi-Fi
यूज़ कर रहा हूं। तो मैं इस पे डबल क्लिक
करूंगा। एंड यहां पे ये Wi-Fi जो इंटरफ़ेस
है वो सेलेक्ट हो जाएगी। यही अपॉपर जो है
मेरा यूज़ होगा। और इसी के ऊपर मॉनिटरिंग
वगैरह जो भी चीजें हैं वो शुरू हो जाएगी।
इंटरसेप्शन ये इंटरसेप्ट करना शुरू कर
देगा ट्रैफिक को। अभी हम आगे इसमें और भी
चीजें देखेंगे। फिलहाल के लिए मैं इसको
क्लोज़ करता हूं। एंड अभी हम प्रैक्टिकल पे
जब आएंगे डेमोंस्ट्रेशन पे तो हम इसको और
भी चीजें देखेंगे। पहले इसको समझना थोड़ा
ज्यादा जरूरी है। पहले हम इसको समझेंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बिफोर वी स्टार्ट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
द वायर शार्क
टॉपिक हमें नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक के बारे में
थोड़ा समझना है। नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक
एक्सैक्टली होता क्या है?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
एंड किस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तरीके
से अ
यू दिस इज़ इन कनेक्टेड टू द वायरश थिंग।
ठीक है? यह हम थोड़ा सा देखेंगे। देखो,
नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक कंसिस्ट ऑफ़ ऑल द डिजिटल
डेटा मूविंग अक्रॉस अ नेटवर्क एट एनी गिवन
इंस्टेंट। पूरे नेटवर्क में आप मान लो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
जो पूरी दुनिया है उस पूरी दुनिया में
अलग-अलग
कॉन्टिनेंट्स अलग-अलग कंट्रीज लाइक
अलग-अलग सिटीज में अलग-अलग कंप्यूटर
सर्वर्स इलेक्ट्रॉनिक मतलब
डिवाइसेस रखे हुए हैं जो इंटरनेट से
कनेक्टेड है। अब वो सारे डिवाइसेस एक
दूसरे से इंटरनेट के थ्रू कनेक्ट हैं। एक
दूसरे से ट्रांसमिशन करते हैं। डेटा का
आदानप्रदान राइट सेंडिंग रिसीविंग ये डेटा
का होता रहता है। अब ये जो डिजिटल डाटा ये
जो डेटा ये जो पैकेट्स उनको पैकेट्स बोल
सकते हैं आईपी पैकेट्स ये जो पैकेट्स हैं
डेटा है जो ये इधर-उधर मूव करते हैं एक
कंप्यूटर से दूसरे दूसरे सिस्टम से तीसरे
सिस्टम ऐसे इंटरनेट पे पूरे वर्ल्ड में
घूमते रहते हैं इनको हम नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक
इन्हीं को बोलते हैं यही है नेटवर्क
ट्रैफिक क्योंकि एक नेटवर्क फॉर्म करते
हैं एक नेटवर्क के अंदर में घूम रहे हैं
ट्रैफिक है जैसे ह्यूमन ट्रैफिक होता है
ह्यूमंस घूम रहे हैं रोड पे वो ट्रैफिक तो
नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] व्हेन यू लोड
अ वेबसाइट जब भी आप एक वेबसाइट लोड करते
हैं एक ईमेल भेजते हैं या कोई वीडियो
स्ट्रीम करते हैं कुछ भी या एक फाइल
डाउनलोड करते हैं कुछ भी करते हैं योर
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम स्प्लिट्स योर पेलोड इनू
स्मॉल मैनेजेबल चंक्स कॉल्ड पैकेट्स। तो
आप जब भी कुछ भी करते हैं तो वो क्या होता
है? छोटे-छोटे चंक्स में ही प्रोसेस होता
है। एंड उन्हीं चंक्स ऑफ डेटा को पैकेट्स
बोलते हैं जो कि स्मालेस्ट यूनिट ऑफ़ डेटा।
बहुत ही सबसे छोटा यूनिट होता है डेटा का
पैकेट्स हम उनको बोलते हैं। ठीक है? दोज़
आर कॉल्ड पैकेट्स। दिस पैकेट्स मूव थ्रू
लेयर्स ऑफ नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल्स। अब ये
पैकेट जो है एक लेयर ऑफ प्रोटोकॉल्स में
घूमते हैं। जैसे ओएसआई मॉडल आपने पढ़ा
होगा ओएसआई मॉडल का जो लेयरिंग होता है
नीचे से ऊपर की तरफ राइट लास्ट में ऊपर
एप्लीकेशन लेयर होता है। ठीक है? फिर
फिजिकल लेयर है ना होता है। फिर डेटा लिंक
लेयर होती है। नेटवर्क लेयर होता है।
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर होता है। फिर
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर होता है। एप्लीकेशन लेयर
होता है। ये नीचे से ऊपर तक लेयर जाते हैं
आपके। राइट? तब ये जो लेयर आपके जा रहे
हैं उसी लेयर में एक लेयर से दूसरे लेयर,
दूसरे लेयर से तीसरे लेयर ऐसे डेटा का
मूवमेंट होता है। ठीक है? नेटवर्क
प्रोटोकॉल में चाहे वो ओएसआई मॉडल की बात
करें या हम टीसीpआईपी मॉडल की बात करें।
एज़ डेटा ट्रेवल्स डाउन द स्टैक। जैसे ही
डेटा डाउन द स्टैक ट्रेवल करती है। ईच
लेयर रैप्स द पेलोड इन इट्स ओन कंट्रोल
मेटा डेटा। जो ईच हर जो लेयर है वो पेलोड
को एक पेलोड का मतलब अभी हम जानेंगे।
पेलोड को अपने एक मेटा डेटा से रैप करके
देती है। रैप कर देती है। उसको फोल्ड कर
देती है। अपने मेटा डेटा उसमें डाल देती
है। अ प्रोसेस कॉल्ड इनकैप्सुलेशन। इसको
हम इनकैप्सुलेशन बोलते हैं। मतलब हर लेयर
पे क्या करती है? जो भी लेयर है हर एक
लेयर पे क्या होता है? वो लेयर अपना एक
मेटा डेटा अपनी एक इंफॉर्मेशन उस
पर्टिकुलर डेटा के अंदर में डाल देता है
या पेलोड जो भी बोल लो और फिर आगे की तरफ
उसको भेज देता है। इस प्रोसेस को
इनकैप्चुलेशन बोलते हैं।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बेसिकली उसमें ये जो डेटा होती है इसमें
दो तरह की चीजें होती हैं। एक हेडर डेटा
होता है जो पैकेट होती है उसमें दो तरह की
चीजें होती हैं। ये सब मैंने पहले भी
बताया हुआ है। हालांकि पैकेट्स वगैरह के
बारे में एंड एक पेलोड होता है। हेडर डेटा
में क्या होता है? ये मैक एड्रेस, IP
एड्रेस, पोर्ट नंबर्स, फ्लैग, सीक्वेंस
नंबर, चेक सम्स ये सब कवर करते हैं, कंटेन
करते हैं। और पेलोड्स में जो एक्चुअल डेटा
होती है जो भेजी जा रही है, ठीक है? वो
डेटा होता है। ये जो चीजें हैं जो लोग
फॉलो कर रहे हैं कंटिन्यू ये चीज़ मैंने
ऑलरेडी डेटा पैकेट्स वाली जो पहले क्लासेस
हुई हैं उनमें सब कुछ बहुत डिटेल में
बताया हुआ है। राइट? तो ये मैं बस समरी एक
कर रहा हूं। एक एक समराइज़ आपको कर रहा
हूं। रिवीज़ के तौर पे मान सकते हैं। तो इस
तरीके से डेटा मूव करती है। ठीक है? तो ये
पूरा का पूरा डेटा मूवमेंट का पूरा
ट्रैफिक के बारे में थोड़ा बहुत मैंने
आपको आईडिया दे दिया क्या ट्रैफिक होती
है? किस तरीके से डेटा मूव करती है ओएसआई
टीसीपी मॉडल में टीसीपी लेयर्स में
टीसीpआईपी लेयर हो गई या ओएसआई लेयर हो गई
उस तरीके से। ठीक है? अब यहां पे आते हैं
कि इन डेटा का जो मूवमेंट है, इन डेटा का
जो ट्रांसमिशन है, इसको हम कैप्चर कर सकते
हैं। इसको हम पकड़ सकते हैं। जैसे बॉबसूट
नाम का टूल आप जानते होंगे। बहुत लोग को
पता होगा शायद। नहीं पता तो Google कर
लीजिएगा। बॉबs क्या करता है? इंटरनेट के
डाटा जिससे आप कनेक्ट कर रहे हैं, इंटरनेट
से जो कनेक्ट कर रहे हैं आप अपने लोकल
कंप्यूटर से तो आपके लोकल कंप्यूटर और
इंटरनेट के बीच के डेटा को कैप्चर कर लेता
है। उसके बाद आपको उस डेटा के ऊपर
प्रोसेसिंग करने का ऑप्शन देता है। मू
मॉडिफाई करने का ऑप्शन देता है और फिर आप
उस डेटा को भेज सकते हैं आगे। राइट? तो
उसी तरीके से वायर शार्क जो होती है ये
वायर शार्क आपके नेटवर्क के अंदर जो भी
डेटा का ट्रांसमिशन होता है उसको पकड़ती
है कैप्चर करती है आपको रियल टाइम में शो
करती है कि रियल टाइम में क्या डाटा जा
रहा है किस तरह की रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है
आपके साइट से या सर्वर से यानी दूसरे
कंप्यूटर से आप पे कौन सा रिस्पांस आ रहा
है किस तरह का डाटा आ रहा है वह सब कुछ
एक-एक डिटेल आपको शो करती है एक-एक डिटेल
आपको शो करती है
दैट्स इट।
ओके।
ओके गाइस। सो अभी मैं चैट पर फोकस नहीं कर
रहा। अभी मैं फोकस थोड़ा कंटेंट पे कर रहा
हूं इधर। तो अभी प्लीज आप भी फोकस कीजिए
इधर। फिर मैं चैट पे आ जाऊंगा आपके साथ।
तो लास्ट में आएंगे तो हम बातें करेंगे।
राइट? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। तो कुछ इस तरीके का इंटरफ़ेस आपको
दिखता है वशार्क का। ये सामने आपको दिख
रहा है। ये Wi शार्क का कुछ इस तरह का
इंटरफ़ेस दिखता है। ठीक है? ये ऊपर में
यहां पे इसकी जो मेन्यू होती है ये सब
मेन्यू है। यहां पे आइकॉन्स मेन्यू है
यहां पे आपके यहां पे अ फिल्टर्स अ सर्च
फिल्टर्स मतलब जो भी आप फिल्टर्स सर्च
करना चाहते हैं सर्च वगैरह कर सकते हैं।
देन मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस यहां पे आपको रिजल्ट
सारे दिखते हैं। सारी जो भी डेटा हैं आने
वाली जाने वाली अपकमिंग जो डाटा है मतलब
आउटगोइंग इनकमिंग डेटा हैं वो सारी दिखती
हैं। क्लाइंट से सर्वर की तरफ जो जा रही
है सर्वर से क्लाइंट की तरफ जो आ रही है
वो सब डेटा यहां दिखती हैं। और डेटा की
फिर पूरी डिटेल जो है वो फ्रेम्स की बात
करें या आईपी की डिटेल्स की बात करें या
व्हाटएवर डिटेल्स लाइक सारी डिटेल्स आपको
यहां पे दिखती है। तो हम एक जानेंगे थोड़ा
डिटेल में आगे चलके।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सबसे पहले
वायरशार्क इज द वॉल्स मोस्ट वाइडली ओपन
सोर्स नेटवर्क पैकेट एनालाइजर टूल। पैकेट
स्निफर या एनालाइजर टूल है। एंड यह ओपन
सोर्स है। बिल्कुल फ्री भी है। ओपन सोर्स
ही सिर्फ नहीं है। यह एब्सोलुटली फ्री टूल
है। दिस इज़ वन ऑफ़ द ग्रेटेस्ट टूल इन
द हिस्ट्री यू कैन से जो कि फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट
है। आपके लिए अवेलेबल है। और इसकी पावर आप
शायद ना जानते होंगे। बट ये साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के अंदर
ये
मतलब साइबर सिक्योरिटी के अंदर यह हैकर्स
के लिए या नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी के अंदर यह
नेटवर्क एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स के लिए या एसओसी
के अंदर एसओसी एनालिस्ट्स के लिए यह वन ऑफ
द मोस्ट डिमांडेड एंड मोस्ट इंटरेस्टिंग
टूल है। एंड हर कोई इसको यूज़ करता है। ठीक
है? अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे आते हैं कि वायर शार्क पैकेट को
कैप्चर कैसे करता है? वायर शार्क पैकेट को
आखिर कैप्चर कैसे करता है? जो कैप्चरिंग
होती है वायर शार्क के अंदर में वो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कैसे कैप्चर
करता है? ये दिस इज़ द दिस शुड बी द
इंपॉर्टेंट थिंग टू आस्क। तो देखो यहां पे
इसके मल्टीपल तरीके होते हैं। एक आपका
प्रॉमिसस मोड होता है। ठीक है? यह
प्रॉमिस्केस मोड जो होता है इसमें आपको
क्या होता है? मैं आपको बताता हूं। बाय
डिफ़ॉल्ट यह जो मोड है, नेटवर्क इंटरफ़ेस
कार्ड जो होते हैं, इसमें एनआईसीज़ ओनली
पास फ्रेम्स एड्रेस टू देयर ओन मैक एड्रेस
अप टू द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। वाशार्क सेट्स द
एनआईसी टू प्रॉमिसकेस मोड जिसको कि आप
नॉर्मल डेली लाइफ के लैंग्वेज में मॉनिटर
मोड बोलते होंगे। राइट? मतलब बहुत लोग को
प्रॉमिसकेस मोड शायद ना पता हो कि
प्रॉमिसकेस क्या होता है। तो आपको मॉनिटर
मोड पता होगा कई आप में से कई लोगों को तो
वो मॉनिटर मोड जो है उसमें सेट कर देता है
आपके एनआईसी को नेटवर्क इंटरफेस कार्ड को।
ठीक है? इवन इफ इट इज़ मिंट फॉर अनदर
डिवाइस। किसी भी यूज़ के लिए हो। उसके बाद
यह होता है कैप्चर कोर लाइब्रेरी। नेक्स्ट
है वाया शार्क रियलाइज़ ऑन लो लेवल पैकेट
कैप्चर लाइब्रेरीज़ टु इंटरफ़ेस
विथ द नेटवर्क कार्ड कर्नल ड्राइवर। ठीक
है? तो वशार्क जो है ना यह एक लो लेवल
पैकेट कैप्चर लाइब्रेरी पे डिपेंड करता
है। ताकि जो टू इंटरफ़ेस विद नेटवर्क कार्ड
ताकि वह नेटवर्क कार्ड कर्नल ड्राइवर से
इंटरफ़ेस कर सके रख सके एंड कनेक्ट हो सके।
तो बेसिकली ये कौन से नेटवर्क कर्नल
ड्राइवर्स होते हैं? एक तो लिब पी कैप
होता है। ये िक्स और लinक्स सिस्टम्स में
होते हैं। और यहां पे एन पीकैप एक होता है
जो कि पहले विन पिककैप नाम से जाना जाता
था। यह Windows सिस्टम पे होता है। मतलब
Windows जब आप यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो NPCAP जो
ड्राइवर है अह उसके साथ काम करती है यह।
और एक लinक्स में लिब पिककैप नाम के उससे
लाइब्रेरी से काम करती है। तो दो
लाइब्रेरीज है लिब पिकैप और एनपीकैप इसके
साथ काम करता है हमारा वाय शार्क किस चीज
के लिए? कैप्चर करने। किस चीज के लिए?
मॉनिटर मोड के थ्रू डेटा को कैप्चर करने
के लिए। उसके बाद आते हैं डाईसेक्टर्स की
बात करते हैं। डाईसेक्टर्स क्या होते हैं
इसमें? वायर शार्क पाससेस रॉ बाइनरी
बाइट्स इनू डाईसेक्टर्स। वशक जो है
डसेक्टर्स में रॉ बाइनरी बाइट्स को क्या
करता है? पास करता है। बिल्ट इन कोड
मॉड्यूल टेलर्ड टू स्पेसिफिक प्रोटोकॉल्स।
इसमें बिल्ट इन कोड मॉड्यूल होता है जो
स्पेसिफिक प्रोटो प्रोटोकॉल्स के लिए
टेलर्ड होते हैं। जैसे कि एचटीडीटीपीएस हो
गया, आपका, डीएनएस हो गया, टीसीp हो गया,
एआरपी हो गया, इन सबके लिए हो गया।
डसेक्टर्स पास द रॉ हेक्स्पाइट्स एंड
ट्रांसलेट देम इंटू अ ह्यूमन रीडेबल
स्ट्रक्चर। तो डसेक्टर्स का काम क्या है?
सिंपल। डसेक्टर का मतलब सिंपल। वाला मैं
समझा देता हूं। देखो वायर शार्क किस तरीके
से काम करता है? वायरशार्क जो है ना रॉ
बाइनरी बाइट्स को डाईसेक्टर्स में पास कर
देता है। बाइनरी बाइट रॉ 01 0 1 0 1 0 1
वाला जो आपने पढ़ा होगा। तो रॉ जो भी अप
डेटा होती है कंप्यूटर को 01 01 समझ में
आता है। अगर आप एप्पल भी लिखते हैं तो
कंप्यूटर को एप्पल कुछ नहीं समझ में आता।
एप्पल क्या है क्या उसको 01 01 फॉर्म में
एप्पल जो है वह समझ में आता है। तो वशक
उसी ज़ीरो वन ज़ीरो 1 एप्पल को रॉ उसी तरीके
से ज़ीरो वन डेट डाइससेक्टर्स में डाल देता
है। ठीक है? डाइससेक्टर जो हैं एक किस
क्या होते हैं डाइससेक्टर एक बिल्ट इन कोड
मॉड्यूल्स उसके अंदर काम कर रही होती है
जो कि स्पेसिफिक प्रोटोकॉल्स के लिए होती
है। बिल्ट इन कोड मॉड्यूल्स होता है। ठीक
है? जैसे डीएनएस के लिए अलग होता है,
सीडीपी के लिए अलग होता है, टीसीपी के लिए
अलग होता है। अब डसेक्टर्स क्या करते हैं?
उन रॉ हेक्स बाइट्स को पास करते हैं और
ह्यूमन रीडेबल
फॉर्म में उसको प्रस्तुत करते हैं आपके
सामने। ह्यूमन रीडेबल फॉर्म में उसको लेकर
आते हैं ताकि ह्यूमन जो है उसको समझ पाए,
पढ़ पाए। ये डसेक्टर्स का काम होता है
वायरशार्क के अंदर में। ठीक है? अब आगे की
तरफ बढ़ते हैं। वायरशार्क के पैकेट
ऑपरेशंस को थोड़ा समझते हैं। पैकेट
ऑपरेशंस क्या होते हैं? अब देखो वायरशार्क
में ना दो तरह की चीजें होती है। मैं
वायरशार्क को स्टार्ट करता हूं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ये वायरशार्क हो गया। Wi-Fi हमारा है। इस
पे ओपन करते हैं। यहां पे कुछ अह
ट्रैफ़िक्स जो है वह चल रही हैं। मैं इसको
फिलहाल के लिए क्या करता हूं? स्टॉप कर
देता हूं। कैप्चरिंग यहां पे। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे आप देखोगे ना तो यहां सबसे ऊपर ये
जो सर्च वाली बार है, यह वाली पर्टिकुलर
बार है। इस पे जब क्लिक करूंगा, तो यहां
लिखा है अप्लाई अ डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर। ठीक?
एक और यहां पे एक एरो की है। यहां पे एक
अप्लाई डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर का एंटर की है। यह
एरो की है। एरो की पे आप क्लिक करेंगे तो
यहां पे कुछ आपको बेसिकली जो भी आपने
रीसेंट में वो यूज़ किया है फ़िल्टर्स वगैरह
जो भी है वो यहां पे आपको देखने को
मिलेगा। बाकी यहां पे आपको आएगा अप्लाई अ
डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर। ठीक है? यहां पे एक प्लस
साइन का होता है। प्लस साइन पे आप क्लिक
करेंगे तो यहां पे आप इन फ़िल्टर्स के को
जो है थोड़ा सा लेबल-वेबल लाइक फ़्टर बटन का
लेवल आपको कुछ चेंज करना है मतलब लेवल
डालना है वो कर कर सकते हैं। उसके बाद
यहां पे फ़्टर एक्सप्रेशंस आपको कुछ अप्लाई
करने हैं तो फ़िल्टर एक्सप्रेशनंस कर सकते
हैं। कमेंट को डालना है तो कमेंट वगैरह ये
सब कर सकते हैं। फ़िल्टर बटन प्रेफरेंस पे
आप आके यहां पे अलग-अलग तरह के लाइक
फ़िल्टर बटंस पे नेम्स पे अलग-अलग तरह के
प्रेफरेंसेस सेटिंग्स हैं आप कर सकते हैं।
अभी फिलहाल जरूरत नहीं है। फिलहाल के लिए
यहां पे सिर्फ हम यहां पे डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर्स वाली जो सर्च ऑप्शन है इसको हम
फिलहाल यूज़ करेंगे। तो वायरशार्क में ना
फ़्टर्स का बहुत बड़ा रोल होता है। राइट?
फिल्टर्स का बहुत बड़ा रोल है। अब फिल्टर्स
के बेसिस पे ही आपका वायर शार्क जो है वो
चलता है। वायरशार्क में फिल्टर्स बहुत
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। इस फिल्टर्स
की लिस्ट अगर आपको चाहिए तो मैं आपको
बोलूंगा वायर शार्क में वायर शार्क
एसएमबी फिल्टर्स
[खांसने की आवाज़]
देखते [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हैं इस
पे शायद पूरी आ जाए तो ठीक है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम
यहां पे आएंगे तो यहां पे इनका आवाशा का
ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट है। इसमें ऑफिशियल वsक
डॉक्स स df आरईf डीएफ मतलब डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर्स आरएफ मतलब रेफरेंस तो डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर रेफरेंस वाली वेबसाइट पे आप आएंगे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो यहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आपको पूरी
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स जो है देखने को यहां पे
मिल जाएगी। अलग-अलग तरह के डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर जो है यहां पे आपको देखने को मिल
जाएंगी। बहुत बहुत डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट टाइप्स
के। अब यहां पे मैं मान लो यहां पे अ वाय
शार्क के फ़िल्टर्स अगर आपको अ हेल्प उसके
रिगार्डिंग हेल्प कुछ देखनी है, कुछ हेल्प
चाहिए, तो आपको वशक फिल्टर वाली पेज पे ये
जो फ़िल्टर वाली पेज है, इस पे आप आ सकते
हैं या तो यूज़र्स गाइड पे आ सकते हैं। तो,
मैं वायरशक फ़िल्टर्स वाली पेज पे आ जाता
हूं। यहां पे फ़िल्टर वाली पेज पे आएंगे।
तो, यह इसका मैनुअल पेज है वशक फ़िल्टर्स
का। आप इस पे आके फिल्टर से रिलेटेड सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन या सारी जो हेल्प है वो आप
यहां ले सकते हैं। इनके ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट
पे देखो इनके ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट पे हर
जानकारी है जो जो आपको चाहिए को समझने के
लिए एक-एक चीज बहुत इतनी डिटेल में है कि
कोई भी बंदा इतनी डिटेल में एक कोई कोर्स
में भी नहीं डाल सकता। क्योंकि अगर वो
सारी डिटेल यहां एंटर करेगा ना अगर कोई
कोर्स बनाता है मान लो वशार्क के ऊपर। ठीक
है? अगर कोई कोर्स बनती है वशार के ऊपर तो
वायरस की कोर्स 50 घंटे की भी अगर होगी
उसमें भी सारी चीजें वो शायद इंक्लूड ना
कर सके कोई भी इंस्टट्यूट या ट्रेनर या
व्हाटएवर क्योंकि ये इतनी ज्यादा चीजें
हैं इसके अंदर में और ये सारी चीजें आपको
इनके ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट पे डॉक्स के अंदर
में जो है वो मिल जाती है। तो यहां फ़्टर्स
में आप आएंगे तो यहां पे इनके सारे
डिटेल्स ऑपरेटर्स के बारे में सर्च एंड
मैच ऑपरेटर्स वगैरह जो है उस वो सब चीजें
फंक्शनंस वो सब चीजें मैस हर चीजें आपको
मिलेंगी। फील्ड टाइप्स प्रोटोकॉल के वो
सारी चीजें मिलेंगी। नीचे की तरफ आप आएंगे
तो आपको बहुत सारी चीजें यहां पे देखने को
मिल जाती है। हां अभी लाइक गाइड वगैरह है।
गाइड पे आप आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको अलग-अलग
तरह के डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स के गाइड ये ऑल
ऑफ वायरस डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स फ्रॉम वन टू
प्रेजेंट यहां पे आप देखेंगे इस पे लिंक
पे जाएंगे। तो आपको अलग-अलग डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर्स यहां मिल जाएंगे। तो उसी वही जो
हमने खोला था वही चीजें हैं। अब मान लो
मैं यहां पे कोई डिस्प्ले एस में चलते
हैं। एस में चलते हैं और कोई डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर देखते हैं। जैसे एस में कोई एक
हम हम प्रोटोकॉल का देख लेते हैं।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम एसएमबी का
मान लो डिस्प्ले फिल्टर है। तो एसएमबी का
डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर है। तो यहां पे 807
फील्ड्स हैं यहां पे। देखिए अब एसएमबी तो
एसएमबी डिस्प्ले फिल्टर पे सर्च करेंगे।
तो आपको एसएमबी से रिलेटेड जितने भी
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स हैं वो सब यहां पे आपको
देखने को मिल जाएंगे। ये एसएमबी में ये
सारे डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स यूज़ होते हैं।
देखो एक पर्टिकुलर प्रोटोकॉल के कितने
सारे डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स हैं। टोटल 807 कुछ
फ़िल्टर्स हैं। आपने देखा होगा यहां पे।
उसी तरीके से हर एक मतलब अगर आपको एचटीटीp
का डिस्प्ले फिल्टर चाहिए तो एच पे आ जाओ।
यहां पे आपको एचटीटीp का डिस्प्ले फिल्टर
मिल जाएगा। मैं यहां पे सर्च कर लेता हूं।
इतना टाइम लगेगा फिर। एचटीटीp सर्च कर
लेते हैं। हां, यह रहा http का।
बी एचttp http यह रहा हाइपर टेक्स्ट
ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल अब इस पे जाते हैं
देखो 102 फील्ड्स 102 डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स
की यहां पर रेफरेंसेस है http डॉट
एक्सेप्ट राइट एचटीp डॉट एक्सेप्ट
इनकोडिंग एचटीडीp ऑथेंटिकेट ये डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर्स हैं एक्चुअली अब जैसे यहां पे
कोई भी चीज आप डालोगे जैसे मैं मान के चल
लो अ http
कंटेंट लेंथ की बात कर रहा हूं मैं ठीक है
मैं इसको कॉपी कर लूंगा वशक में आऊंगा तो
यहां पे आप इस डिस्प्ले फिल्टर को डाल के
यहां पे डालोगे एचटीडीटीp कंटेंट लेंथ तो
तो आपको यहां पे ऑप्शन मिल जाएगा। अब यहां
पे आपको एचटीडीपी कंटेंट लेंथ अ जो है
कंटेंट लेंथ अब इसके अंदर कोई और भी
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर की अगर ऑप्शन होंगे तो
आपको जैसे ही कंटेंट लेंथ डालोगे ना तो
इसका सजेशन आ जाएगा कि कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर
करके भी एक डिस्प्ले फिल्टर है। तो कंटेंट
लेंथ हेडदर कर देंगे तो यहां से आपको
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडदर की मिल जाएगी। अब इसके
बाद आपको जो जो आर्गुमेंट्स देने हैं जो
भी आप वो देने हैं आप दे सकते हैं। सिंपल
सिंपल सा फंडा है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे मैं
कंटेंट लेंथ एचटीडीटीp कंटेंट लेंथ पे अगर
यहां पे रहता हूं और मैं एंटर कर देता हूं
तो एचटीडीपी कंटेंट लेंथ के अकॉर्डिंग जो
भी यहां पे रिजल्ट आएगा मुझे अगर यहां पे
कुछ मिलता है तो यहां पे मुझे देखने को
मिल जाएगा। फिलहाल के लिए यहां पे हम कुछ
भी नहीं है। यहां पे मैं यहां हटा देता
हूं। कुछ ये शायद हैंग कर गया क्या?
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके। इसको अभी बंद कर दिया हमने। फिर से
स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं। कुछ मे कुछ होगा।
अ वाईफाई जो है हमारी वाई-फाई वाली
स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं। चलो ये हो रहा है
हमारा। चलो इसको होने देते हैं। कुछ देर
होने देते हैं। इसको होने ही देते हैं।
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। उसी तरीके से यहां पे
अलग-अलग फ़िल्टर्स हैं। एचटीडीp के एचtडीp
एक्सेप्ट ये सब करके हैं। एचटीडीp रेंज,
http सारे। तो एचटीपी रिस्पांस ये सारी
चीज़ एचटीपी एसएस पोर्ट एचटीडीटीp कुकी ये
सब करके आप फ़िल्टर कर सकते हैं। एचटीडीटीp
रेंज फ़िल्टर कर सकते हैं। राइट? तो इस
तरीके की आपको फ़िल्टर्स आपको देखने को मिल
जाते हैं। अब यहां पे इन ऑपरेशंस में
जो फ़्टर्स की जब बात करते हैं, तो वायर
शार्क यूसेस टू डिस्टिंक्ट फ़िल्टरिंग
सिंटेक्सेस। दो तरह के सिंटेक्स फ़्टर
सिंटेक्स को ये यूज़ करता है। दोनों में से
आप कोई सा भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं। डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर्स जो है मोस्ट वाइडली यूज़्ड होते
हैं। एंड ज्यादातर डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स को
लोग यूज़ अ करते हैं। ठीक है? तो अब यहां
पे हम दोनों फ़िल्टर्स की बात करते हैं।
वायरशार्क में अंदर कौन-कौन क्या-क्या
होता है? बेसिकली एक होता है आपका कैप्चर
फिल्टर। ठीक है? इसको हम बीपीएफ सिंटेक्स
बोलते हैं। और एक होता है डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर। इसको हम वायरशार्क सिंटेक्स बोलते
हैं। ठीक है? क्योंकि डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर जो
है वाइडली यूज़ होते हैं मोस्ट ऑफ़ द टाइम।
वाशार्क में भी आपने देखा होगा कि वहां
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर लिखा होता है जनरली बाय
डिफॉल्ट। तो इसको ज्यादातर यूज़ में लिया
जाता है। अब देखो कैप्चर फिल्टर और
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर में एक्चुअली अंतर क्या
होता है? उसको हम समझते हैं। वायरशार्क को
समझना है तो आपको वायरशार्क के कांसेप्ट्स
और फिल्टर्स और इसके एनालिसिस की पावर को
समझना होगा। नहीं समझेंगे कुछ नहीं समझ
में आएगा आपको वायरशार्क। आप भी एक
स्क्रिप्ट किडी की तरह रह जाएंगे। जैसे
स्क्रिप्ट किडी किसी भी टूल को क्या करते
हैं? थोड़ा बहुत उसके बारे में देखते हैं।
उसकी हेल्प लेते हैं। उसको यूज़ कर लेते
हैं। अपना काम कर लेते हैं। बात खत्म। वो
टूल के बारे में नहीं जानते। टूल के
कांसेप्ट्स के बारे में नहीं जानते। टूल
को क्यों एक्चुअली यूज़ में लिया जा रहा
है? उसके बारे में ज्यादा कुछ नहीं पता।
टूल के बैक एंड की टेक्नोलॉजी के बारे में
नहीं पता। टूल बैक एंड में कैसे काम कर
रहा है। किस टेक्नोलॉजी पे काम कर रहा है?
किस तरीके से काम कर रहा है वो पूरा
प्रोसेस नहीं पता। टूल यूज़। उनको हम बोलते
हैं स्क्रिप्ट किडीज़। तो अगर आपको
स्क्रिप्ट किडी बनना है तो दैट्स इट। यह
इतना वारश में काफी है। बट अगर आपको
एक्चुअल स्किल्ड पर्सन बनना है, एक
एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट बनना है, साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट बनना है, तो आपके लिए
दिस इज़ वेरी वेरीेंट।
ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] या
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वो क्रैश करता
है नॉट एन इशू। तो अब जब कैप्चर फिल्टर्स
को अप्लाई करते हैं व्हेन अप्लाई तो बिफोर
या ड्यूरिंग पैकेट कैप्चर।
कब अप्लाई किया जाता है पैकेट फ़िल्टर्स
को? तो जब बिफोर या ड्यूरिंग द पैकेट
कैप्चर। जब कैप्चर आप कर रहे हैं तब भी आप
अप्लाई कर सकते हैं या उसके पहले भी कर
सकते हैं। डिस्प्ले फीचर फिल्टर कब अप्लाई
होता है? आफ्टर पैकेट कैप्चर ऑन सेव्ड
मेमोरी। डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स को पैकेट
कैप्चर के बाद अप्लाई जनरली किया जाता है।
और कैप्चर और इसको आप ड्यूरिंग द पैकेट
कैप्चर भी आप कैप्चर फिल्टर्स को अप्लाई
कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? अब देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
पर्पस क्या है?
कैप्चर फिल्टर का पर्पस क्या है? सेव्स
डिस्क स्पेस बाय डिस्क कार्डिंग अनवांटेड
पैकेट्स इंस्टेंटली। अब क्योंकि यह आप
ड्यूरिंग कैप्चरिंग भी इसको अप्लाई कर
सकते हो जो आपका ये कैप्चर फिल्टर है। तो
डिस्क पे सेव करने की जरूरत है ही नहीं।
पैकेट्स की डिटेल्स पैकेट्स की चीजें। तो,
ये ड्यूरिंग द जो चीजें हैं, आपकी मेमोरी
के अंदर ही आपका एग्जीक्यूशन हो रहा है।
सब कुछ आप फिल्टर-उल्टर कर सकते हैं।
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर में क्या है? हाइड्स
इररेिलवेंट पैकेट्स विदाउट डिलीटिंग डेटा
फ्रॉम मेमोरी। ये क्या करते हैं? इरिवेंट
इरिलेवेंट पैकेट्स को क्या करते हैं? हाइड
कर देते हैं डेटा को बिना मेमोरी से डिलीट
किए हुए। मतलब जो भी फालतू के पैकेट्स हैं
उनको हाइड कर देते हैं।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
इनका सिंटेक्स स्टाइल क्या है कैप्चा
फिल्टर का? ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो जैसे
इसमें एक बार्कली पैकेट फ़िल्टर की बात
करें तो कुछ इस तरीके से ये फ़्टर होते
हैं। जैसे मान लो कि हमें एक फ़िल्टर है
होस्ट। यह होस्ट है हमारा। होस्ट की आईपी
दे दो। एंड पोर्ट 80 मतलब हमें इस होस्ट
को शो करो। इस होस्ट के पैकेट्स को शो करो
जो कि 19268.1.1
IP वाली होस्ट्स हैं सारे इसको शो करो।
एंड उस कौन से पोर्ट के कौन से पोर्ट पे
शो करो सारे? 80 वाले पोर्ट के। मतलब यह
होस्ट इस पोर्ट पे जितने भी होस्ट हैं यह
होस्ट और इस पोर्ट की जितनी भी रिक्वेस्ट
हैं सॉरी इस पर्टिकुलर होस्ट के इस पोर्ट
पे जितने भी ट्रैफिक हैं जितने भी
रिक्वेस्ट मतलब रिस्पांस रिक्वेस्ट जो भी
हैं वो सब शो कर इस तरीके का इंटर इनका
सिंटेक्स होता है। बट डिस्प्ले
एक्सप्रेशनंस कैसे होते हैं? अब मान लो कि
इस होस्ट के बारे में पता करना है। उसके
सारे रिक्वेस्ट रिप्लाई तो IP एड्रेस हमें
यहां लिखना होता है। IP डॉट एडर इक्वल्स
इक्वल्स मतलब ये डबल इक्वल इक्वल के बराबर
यहां पे माना जाता है। एंड एंड दो बार एंड
एंड के बराबर माना जाता है। टीसीp पोर्ट
कौन सा पोर्ट? AT तो दोनों का काम एक ही
है बट दोनों का सिंटेक्स अलग है। तो एक
कैप्चा फिल्टर है। एक है डिस्प्ले फिल्टर।
अब दोनों तरीके से कर सकते हैं। याद रखिए
कैप्चर फिल्टर को आप ड्यूरिंग पैकेट
कैप्चर भी यूज कर सकते हैं। उसके पहले कर
सकते हैं। बट बाद में अगर करना हो जैसे
कैप जो आपका पैकेट है उसको आप कैप्चर करना
बंद कर चुके हैं। आप पैकेट कैप्चरिंग बंद
कर चुके हैं। स्टॉप कर चुके हैं। अब आपको
फिल्टर्स अप्लाई करना है तो आप डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर अप्लाई कर सकते हैं। ड्यूरिंग करना
है तो आप फिर कैप्चर फिल्टर भी अप्लाई कर
सकते हैं। सीपीू लोड की अगर बात करें तो
क्योंकि यह तो आप ड्यूरिंग भी कर सकते
हैं। तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है यह लोड कम
डालेगा आपके सीपीयू के ऊपर में। ठीक है?
ड्राइवर लेवल पे यह प्रोसेस होता है। और
यह स्टोर हो रहा है। बेसिकली चीजों को
स्टोर कर रहा है मेमोरी सेव्ड मेमोरी के
अंदर। तो, यहां पे थोड़ी सी हाई इसकी लोड
पड़ेगी। यह दो तरह के फिल्टर्स होते हैं
जो बेसिकली वारशाक यूज़ करते हैं। आगे की
तरफ बढ़ते हैं। वाशक पैकेट ऑपरेशंस में ही
हम यहां पे कुछ क्रूशियल डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर्स की अगर बात करें तो फ़्टर बाय
आईपीस होते हैं। फ़्टर बाय प्रोटोकॉल होते
हैं। फ़िल्टर बाय पोर्ट्स होते हैं। फ़्टर
बुलियन ऑपरेटर्स होते हैं। फील्ड मैचिंग्स
होते हैं। ये सारी चीज़ होती हैं। देखो ये
तो बहुत छोटा सा मैंने लिस्ट दिया है।
बहुत छोटा सा। बहुत ह्यूज लिस्ट है गाइज़।
आप याद नहीं कर सकते हैं। मतलब हजारों में
फिल्टर्स हैं। यू कैन नॉट रिमेंबर और
मेमोराइज एवरीथिंग। यू हैव टू यूज़ द चीट
शीट। यू हैव टू यूज़ द अ डॉक्यूमेंट्स
डॉक्स राइट? टू यूज़ दोज़ फीचर्स। अब वशार्क
जब आप यूज़ करेंगे फ्रीक्वेंटली, तो आपको
कुछ फ़िल्टर्स तो हैं जो फ्रीक्वेंट यूज़
करने पड़ेंगे। जो आपको याद हो जाएगा। ठीक
है? कुछ ऑपरेटर्स फ़िल्टर्स फ़िल्टर्स कुछ
ऑपरेटर्स आपको याद हो जाएंगे। यूज़
करते-करते प्रैक्टिस हो जाती है। ये कॉमन
चीज है। बट जो रेगुलर प्रैक्टिस में नहीं
होगी वो आप शायद याद नहीं रख पाएंगे। तो
आपको देखना वो पड़ेगा। उसका उसके अलावा और
कोई ऑप्शन इसमें नहीं है। ठीक है? अब जैसे
फ़िल्टर बाय IP तो IP से कैसे फिल्टर
करेंगे? तो IP डॉट एसआरसी आईपी सोर्स आईपी
ये है और IP डेस्टिनेशन डेस्टिनेशन आईपी
ये है। तो आई फ़िल्टर आईपी बाय फिल्टर
फ़िल्टर बाय आईपी हो गई। प्रोटोकॉल से
फिल्टर करना है तो डीएनएस एचटीटीपी एआरपी
आईसीएमपी टीएलएस ऐसे करके कि डीएनएस वाले
प्रोटोकॉल वाले कितने हैं एचटीडीपीएस वाले
कितने हैं जैसे मतलब मान लो ये वाशक चल
रहा है अब मैं एचटीdटीp वाले या एचटीपीएस
वाले फ़्टर करना चाहता हूं या एचटीडीटीp
वाले फ़्टर करना चाहता हूं तो यहां पे यहां
पे मैं करके एंटर करूंगा तो एचटीडीटीp
वाले ये काम करेंगे एचटीडीटीp वाले जो भी
यहां पे प्रोटोकॉल है ये आपको यहां पे
दिखा देंगे तो जैसे आप दिख रहा होगा कि
यहां पे एचटीटीp वाला जो भी यहां पे हमारे
पास अह ट्रैफिक है वो यहां पे अब शो हो
रहा है हमारे पास प्रोटोकॉल एचटीडीटीp
वाला। अब डीएनएस का कोई अगर है तो शो
करेगा। नहीं होगा तो नहीं शो करेगा। तो
डीएनएस वाली है कोई हां डीएनएस वाले जितने
भी यहां पे आप क्वेरीज़ जो जितने भी
ट्रैफिक हैं वो सारे अब डीएनएस वाले शो
करेंगे जब आप डीएनएस करेंगे। तो ये
बेसिकली क्या होता है? ये आपका होता है अ
फ़िल्टर फ़िल्टर बाय प्रोटोकॉल। अब फ़िल्टर
बाय पोर्ट भी कर सकते हैं आप। फ़िल्टर बाय
पोर्ट कैसे? जैसे TCP पोर्ट कौन से पोर्ट
को फ़िल्टर करना है? 443 यूडीपी पोर्ट
इक्वल टू इसमें इक्वल इक्वल्स का गेम है
यहां पे। तो मैं मान लो यहां पे टीसीp
पोर्ट फिल्टर कर रहा हूं और मैं यहां पे
इक्वल्स इक्वल्स डाल रहा हूं पोर्ट नंबर
443 ठीक है तो अब मैं एंटर करता हूं कोई
43 वाला अगर है अवेलेबल तो आ जाएगा जी हां
बिल्कुल यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
कि यहां पे 443 वाले सारे यहां पे 443
वाले आपको यहां पे देखने को मिलेंगे जितने
भी 443 वाले अब यहां देखते हैं क्या 25
पोर्ट वाला है कोई आपका इज़ देयर एनी 25
पोर्ट रिजल्ट ट्रैफिक नहीं कोई 25 पोर्ट
ट्रैफिक नहीं है 21 एफटीपी का कोई पोर्ट
का है कुछ हम नहीं कोई सा भी पोर्ट नहीं
है ठीक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है 55
पोर्ट है कोई आई थिंक होना चाहिए है देखते
हैं हम
नहीं है चलिए 465 पोर्ट देख लेते हैं
अलग-अलग प्रोटोकॉल्स के लिए पोर्ट्स
अलग-अलग पोर्ट्स होते हैं। हम उनको यहां
पे फ़्टर करने की कोशिश कर रहे हैं। यहां
पे कोई सा भी पोर्ट यहां पे कोई सा भी यह
पोर्ट यह वाला भी यहां पे हमारे पास नहीं
है। क्या हमारे पास
80 80 पोर्ट का है। प्रॉक्सी एचटीp इज देन
एनी प्रॉक्सी नहीं 80 का है। 80 का तो
होगा ही होगा। ऑब्वियसली बात है। तो हमारे
पास 80 पोर्ट के यहां पे अ ये सारे
ट्रैफिक्स हैं। सो ऑल दिस ट्रैफिक्स आर
एटी पोर्ट। तो इस तरीके से पोर्ट
फिल्टरिंग फ़िल्टर बाय पोर्ट कर सकते हैं।
राइट? उसी तरीके से IP का भी कर सकते हैं।
सब कुछ हो सब कुछ पॉसिबल है। अब इन्हीं
में यहां पे कुछ चीज़ें होती है। बुलियन
ऑपरेटर्स क्या होते हैं ये? जैसे IP डॉट
एडर IP एड्रेस इक्वल्स इक्वल्स ये हो गया
एंड एंड
एक्सक्लेमेशन
TCP डॉट पोर्ट इज इक्वल टू AT तो यहां पे
जो एंड एंड है वो आपका बुलियन ऑपरेटर हो
गया। ये कंबाइन करने के लिए यूज़ में लिया
जा रहा है। कंबाइन करने के लिए यहां पे
यूज़ में लिया जा रहा है। तो जैसे अगर दो
चीजों को दो रिजल्ट्स को आप कंबाइन करना
चाहते हैं। दो सर्च रिजल्ट्स को आप कंबाइन
करना चाहते हैं तो आप बुलियन ऑपरेटर्स को
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। हालांकि फिर भी फिर अगेन
इसकी एक पूरी लिस्ट है। मैं आपको अगर
यहां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आप सीधा
सर्च कर सकते हैं। यहां पे सिंपल सा सर्च
कर सकते हैं।
अ वायर शार्क चीट शीट इस तरीके से सर्च
करेंगे आप तो आपको वायर शार्क की चीटशीट
आपको मिल जाएंगे यहां पे स्टेशन एक्स के
तरफ से ही आप इस पे आएंगे नीचे की तरफ
स्क्रॉल करेंगे तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जैसे एनमप की
चीटशीट आती है वैसे ही वश की ट आती है तो
आपको इसमें जो है अलग-अलग तरह के ऑपरेटर्स
जो हैं आपको मिल जाएंगे जैसे वहां पे हमने
देखा था अभी एंड एंड ये जो एंड एंड और एंड
एंड ये वाला वही जो बुलियन आपको अभी हमने
जस्ट अभी थोड़ी देर पहले जो देखा था यहां
पे राइट बुलियन ऑपरेटर्स जो देखा था वही
है। उसके बाद यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आएंगे
तो फ़्टरिंग पैकेट्स जो है डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर्स वो आपको देखने को मिल जाएंगे।
जैसे कि ईक्यू आप यूज़ कर सकते हैं
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर में या डबल इक्वल्स यूज़
कर सकते हैं। वही चीज है यहां पे। ne नॉट
इक्वल या एक्सक्लेमेशन इज इक्वल टू नॉट
इक्वल आपका हो जाता है। कुछ इस तरीके से
gt और ग्रेटर का ये आई टी और लेस का मतलब
इस तरी इस तरीके से ये अलग-अलग तरह के
फ़्टरिंग ऑप्शंस आपको मिलते हैं। ठीक है?
तो कैप्चर फ़िल्टर फ़िल्टर फ़िल्टर पैकेट्स
ड्यूरिंग द कैप्चर डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर हाइड
पैकेट्स फ्रॉम अ कैप्चर कैप्चर डिस्प्ले।
ये आपको मैंने बता दिया ऑलरेडी यहां पे।
दो तरह के मोड यहां पे आपको बता दिए हैं
मैंने ऑलरेडी। यहां पर नीचे की तरफ आएंगे
तो कैप्चर फिल्टर का यहां पर आपको क्या
मिलेगा? सिंटेक्स आपको देखने को मिलेगा।
कुछ इस तरीके से देख सकते हैं यहां पे
सिंटेक्स में कैप्चर फिल्टर का कुछ इस
तरीके से और डिस्प्ले फिल्टर का यहां पे
सिंटेक्स आपको कुछ इस तरीके से मिलेगा।
ठीक है? बस ये चीज है। बस यहां पे जैसे आप
टीसीp सोर्स ये हो गया वैल्यू इतना हो
गया। एंड ये लॉजिकल ऑपरेटर यहां पे
सिंबल्स के अकॉर्डिंग यहां पे आपका ये काम
करता है। शॉर्टकट्स आ गए। यहां पे
शॉर्टकट्स की जरूरत यहां पे है नहीं। यहां
पे कुछ कॉमन फ़िल्टरिंग कमांड्स अगर देखें
तो फ़िल्टर बाय आईपी जो मैं अभी यहां पे
बता रहा था वही चीज़ है यहां पे जो अभी आई
वास टेलिंग यू ये फ़िल्टर बाय IPपी फिल्टर
बाय प्रोटोकॉल यही चीज़ है। फ़िल्टर बाय
आईपी अगर करनी हो तो IP एड्रेस IP ऐड
या एडर इक्वल्स इक्वल्स ये हो गया। फ़िल्टर
बाय डेस्टिनेशन IP IP डॉट डेस्ट इक्वल्स
इक्वल्स IP डॉट सोर्स इक्वल्स इक्वल्स ठीक
है? है। फ़िल्टर बाय आईपी रेंज अगर आपको
डिफाइन करनी है तो कुछ इस तरीके से आप कर
सकते हैं। राइट? सबनेट फ़िल्टर करना है कुछ
इस तरीके से करते हैं। अगर फ़िल्टर बाय
यूआरएल करना है तो http होस्ट और होस्ट
नेम दे दीजिए तो फ़िल्टर बाय यूआरएल हो
जाएगा। राइट? फिर पोर्ट का TCP वही वाला
जो मैंने बताया वो सारी चीजें। तो, यह
पूरी की पूरी एक चीटशीट है। आई वुड
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू कम हियर एंड जस्ट
गेट दिस चीटशीट। इस चीटशीट को आप फॉलो कर
सकते हैं। दिस इज़ ट्रस्टेड चीटशीट एंड सही
अच्छी है। सही है। सब कुछ बढ़िया आप
फिल्टर्स का यूज़ यहां पे कर सकते। क्योंकि
वैसे अगर आप वायरश की फिल्टर्स को देखेंगे
तो बहुत ज्यादा गाइज़ बड़ी है। बहुत ज्यादा
डिफ़ॉल्ट जो इनका वो आप उसमें कंफ्यूज हो
जाएंगे कि क्या है कैसा है। दिमाग आपका
देख रहे हो आप। एक-एक प्रोटोकॉल के लिए
यहां पे कितने सारे फ़िल्टर्स हैं। एक-एक
प्रोटोकॉल के लिए। जस्ट अ सिंगल प्रोटोकॉल
एंड देयर आर अ लॉट ऑफ़ लॉट ऑफ़ फ़िल्टर्स
हियर। अगर अब मैं बैक करूं तो आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे इंडेक्स में कितने यहां पे 1
2 3 4 से लेके ए बी सी डी जेड तक ये सब
दिया हुआ है यहां पे। तो हर चीज़ का यहां
पे फ़िल्टर है। डिबग रिकॉर्डिंग ट्रेस यहां
पे एस्ट्रा सिग्नलिंग प्रोटोकॉल इसमें मैं
जाता हूं यहां पे तो इसके फिर जो जो भी
यहां पे अगर कोई फ़िल्टर आता है तो यहां पे
ये सारे फ़िल्टर्स हैं। अलग-अलग
प्रोटोकॉल्स अलग-अलग चीज़ों के लिए अलग-अलग
फ़िल्टर्स यहां पे आपके हैं। अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे आते
हैं।
ठीक है? ठीक है? यहां पे एक फील्ड मैचिंग
भी होती है। लाइक कोई खास इंपॉर्टेंट है
नहीं। हम बाद में इसको देख भी लेंगे।
नॉर्मल सी चीज है। अब यहां पे डिकोडिंग
एंड स्टैंडर्ड ऑपरेशन को हम थोड़ा सा
देखते हैं। डिकोडिंग एंड स्टैंडर्ड ऑपरेशन
में क्या होता है? फॉलो स्ट्रीम डिकोडिंग
एज दो तरह के आपको ऑप्शन यहां पे देखने को
मिलते हैं। देखो राइट क्लिकिंग अ पैकेट
एंड सेलेक्टिंग फॉलो टीसीपी स्ट्रीम
आइसोलेट्स ऑल पैकेट्स विद इन दैट
स्पेसिफिक कनेक्शन एंड रिकंस्ट्रक्ट द रॉ
कन्वर्सेशनल पेलोड इंटू सीक्वेंशियल
टेक्स्ट। मतलब जो भी चीजें आपको रॉ
फॉर्मेट में देखना है तो आप उसको ऐसे फॉलो
टीसी स्ट्रीम दे करके देख सकते हैं वाशर
के अंदर में जैसे मेरा वाशर का मैं ये
फिल्टर्स हटा देता हूं फिलहाल के लिए ठीक
है
क्या हुआ
ओके मैंने स्टॉप कर दिया यहां पे फिलहाल
के लिए एंड यहां पे बहुत सारे फ़िल्टर्स
यहां पे आ रहे हैं राइट राइट वी हैव अ लॉट
ऑफ़ फ़िल्टर रोल लॉट ऑफ़ ट्रैफिक यहां पे। हम
इसमें कोई से भी ट्रैफिक को ले सकते हैं।
चूज़ एज अ एग्जांपल मैं यहां पे जस्ट अ
सेकंड गाइस।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
जस्ट सेकंड गाइस।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम ये लास्ट में आ गया लास्ट उस पे मान लो
कि यह डाटा है। यह एक ट्रैफिक है। यह एक
डाटा फ्लो है। मान लो कुछ भी कुछ भी
एप्लीकेशन डाटा या यह हो गई कुछ भी
व्हाटएवर। ठीक है? तो अब मान लो यहां पे
मैं राइट क्लिक करूंगा। यहां पे यहां पे
फॉलो पे जाऊंगा और टीसीp स्ट्रीम पे क्लिक
कर दूंगा। ठीक है? फॉलो टीसीपी स्ट्रीम।
अब इस पे जब मैं क्लिक करूंगा ना तो मुझे
एक रॉ फॉर्मेट में ना इसकी जो भी जानकारी
है वो यहां पे मिल जाएंगी। यहां पे एकदम
रॉ फॉर्मेट में कुछ भी व्हाटएवर। लाइक इस
इसमें कोई मीनिंगफुल डेटा नहीं है। कुछ
मीनिंगफुल का भी वो डेटा नहीं है। इसलिए
आपको थोड़ा डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ पासिंग में
दिख रहा है यहां पे। बट जब भी हम कोई
मीनिंगफुल डेटा की बात करते हैं कुछ भी
देखेंगे। जैसे मैं मान लो को मान लो मैं
नीचे आ गया। यहां पे मैं नीचे आ रहा हूं।
ठीक है? अब मैं यहां पे लेट्स सपोज़ कि अ
व्हाट टाइप ऑफ़ डेटा आई शुड चेक हियर।
लेट्स सी टेस्ट पी PHP देख लेते हैं यहां
पे। टेस्ट पी PHP वन वेब आई थिंक ये
वेबसाइट बंद हो गई है या spx देख लेंगे।
देख लेते हैं एक बार जस्ट
टेस्टिंग।
ओके। टेस्ट एएसपी देख लेते हैं इफ दैट इज
वर्किंग
हम
कोई बात नहीं है टेस्ट पीएp का मान लो
यहां पे हमने भेजा था डाटा हमने भेजा हमने
किया यहां पे अब
मैं यहां पर कुछ भी डेfroniccom ओपन करते
हैं एक बार
कुछ इस तरीके से राइट तो हमारे पास
अलग-अलग तरह के डाटा यहां पर आते रहेंगे
लाइक व्हाटएवर डाटा वी आर ट्राइंग टू फैच
और व्हाटएवर तो अभी हम यहां पे स्टॉप करके
रखा है हमने तो हम यहां पे एक बार कैप्चर
फिल्टरिंग स्टार्ट कर देते हैं फिर हम
देखते हैं करके अ कंटिन्यू विदाउट सेविंग
मैं यहां पे डिफ्रॉनिक्स को लोड कर देता
हूं एंड यहां पे टेस्ट
एएसपी कुछ करके देखते हैं इफ देयर इज़ ओपन
अ कोई सा वेबसाइट
लाइक व्हाट एवर एसपी डन या कुछ भी है खुले
या ना खुले उससे मतलब नहीं है बट हमारे
पास डेट है यहां पे कुछ
ओके डज नॉट सपोर्ट
ओके कोई बात नहीं है बट हमारे यहां पे
बहुत सारी डेटा यहां पे आ जा रही है मैं
इसको फिलहाल स्टॉप कर रहा हूं तो जो भी
डेटा यहां पे जैसे हमारे पास आ रही है
राइट अब यहां पे अ टीसीपी स्ट्रीम इक्वल्स
इसको मैं हटा देता हूं फिलहाल के लिए। एंड
यहां पे चलते हैं। लेट्स सपोज ऊपर की तरफ
बहुत सारे यहां पे डाटा हमारे पास आए हैं।
एप्लीकेशन डाटा दिस ऑल डेटा कोई सी भी
रिक्वेस्ट है मान लो व्हाटएवर रिक्वेस्ट
इज़ देयर राइट क्लिक करके फॉलो करते हैं
टीसीp स्ट्रीम। इफ देयर इज़ देयर विल बी नो
मीनिंगफुल ऑब्वियसली डाटा। क्योंकि हमारे
पास कोई भी डेटा पैकेट का कुछ अभी सीन है
नहीं यहां पे। अगर हमारा कुछ एप्लीकेशन
डाटा पैकेट या कुछ ऐसा होता तो हम यहां पे
देख पाते। इफ देयर इज़ सम डाटा। नो लेट्स
सी
हम हम
या नॉर्मल अगर हम कोई लॉग इन का भी देख
लेते हैं ना हम जैसे कोई सिंपल सा लॉग इन
पेज देख लेते हैं
लाइक सपोज
हिंदुस्तान टाइम्स
यहां पर चलते हैं। लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज सम
लॉग इन पेज। यस देयर इज सम लॉग इन पेज।
सो अगर मैं इसको भी स्टार्ट करता हूं यहां
पे।
एंड लेट्स क्लिक ऑन द लॉग इन।
यहां पे मैं यहां पे लॉग इन करता हूं।
यहां पे मान लो यहां पे लॉग इन करते हैं।
तो यहां पे यह लॉग इन पेज का बेसिकली यहां
पे आपको डाटा थोड़ा यहां पे डाटा आ जाएगी
उस जगह से। एंड यहां पे यू विल गेट
डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ डेटाज़ ट्रैफिक जो है वो
आपको यहां पे देखने को मिलेगा। इसमें
अलग-अलग तरह की डेटाज़ अलग-अलग तरह की
चीजें हैं जो आप उसको लाइक फॉलो करके TCP
स्ट्रीम को फॉलो करके आप ड्रॉ फॉर्मेट में
देख सकते हैं। ये TCP स्ट्रीम को फॉलो
करने का ये एक तरीका होता है। राइट? जहां
से आप जो है जानकारियां ले सकते हैं उस
पर्टिकुलर ट्रैफिक के बारे में। जो भी
ट्रैफिक चल रही है उस ट्रैफिक के बारे में
आपको पूरी रॉ फॉर्मेट में जानकारी चाहिए।
तो आपको TCP स्ट्रीम जो है वह आपको डिलीवर
करके देता है। वह आपको बताता है। एग्जैक्ट
आपको चीजें बताता है। मैं यहां पे कोई
टेस्ट वेबसाइट ओपन कर नहीं पा रहा हूं
क्योंकि
मुझे लग रहा है वब डायरेक्ट मैं ओपन कर
लेता हूं। आई थिंक दैट वुड बी फाइन।
वब जो है मैं डायरेक्ट ओपन कर लेता हूं।
मतलब इसमें से कोई से भी उठा लेंगे। एक एक
इफ देयर
कोई वर्किंग अ उठा लेते हैं।
वेब मशीन उठा ले क्या?
चलो
ओके वेब मशीन को स्टार्ट यहां पे वेब मशीन
को उठा लेते हैं यहां पे। राइट? तो मान लो
यहां पे ये वेब मशीन है कुछ भी लाइक
व्हाटएवर अबाउट वेब मशीन है मैं यहां पे
अब डाउनलोड या डिस्क्रिप्शन डिस्क्रिप्शन
पे चल लेते हैं मीडियम ठीक है मैं मान लो
नेटवर्किंग का यहां पे स्क्रीनशॉट है ठीक
है इसको ओपन कर लिया यहां पे एंड
डाउनलोड्स पे यहां पे ये तो पूरा ही वो
करना पड़ेगा डाउनलोड ही करना पड़ेगा दूसरा
तो ऑप्शन यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए
नहीं है नहीं है नहीं है मैं इसको को एक
बार चेक कर लेता हूं। इफ देयर इज समथिंग।
हम हम
इंक्रिप्टेड डेटा यहां पे एक इन यहां पे
भी एक डेटा जैसे एक डाटा मिली है।
इंक्रिप्टेड डेटा है। तो आप इसको फॉलो
यहां पे करेंगे टीसीp स्ट्रीम या डीएलएसएम
तो यहां पे मिलेगी डेटा। बट वही है कि ये
इंक्रिप्टेड डेटा है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है।
तो आपको यहां पे टेक्स्ट जो है क्लियर
उसमें नहीं मिलेगा। देखने को नहीं मिलेगा।
बट कोई अगर नॉन इंक्रिप्टेड डेटा होगी तो
आपको यहां पे देखने को जैसे आप फॉलो
करेंगे टीसी स्ट्रीम करेंगे तो आपको यहां
पे वो एक परफेक्ट उसमें दिख जाएगी। ठीक
है? तो यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए हमारे पास
कोई ऐसा कुछ डाटा देखने को मिल नहीं रहा
है। ना ही तो कोई वेब पेज अ
प्रीबिल्ट मशीनंस मैं चाहता हूं देख लेना
प्रीबिल्ट
इफ देयर इज़ सम
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
लेट्स सी
अ डीवीडब्ल्यू ए
डीवीडब्ल्यूए ऑनलाइन का कुछ है क्या?
अगर ऑनलाइन होगा तो हमारे काम आ जाएगा।
यह वेब प्लेटफार्म है क्या यार? वेब पेज
तो शायद यह वेब वाली तो शायद नहीं काम
करेगी।
हम ये ब्लॉग है। मुझे पता था यह वेब वाली
इनका यह वर्क नहीं करेगा।
आई वांट टू ओपन अ वेब वलनेरेबल वनरेबल
एप्लीकेशन। कोई सा भी एक ओपन कर लेते हैं।
कोई सा भी एक वलेबल मशीन ओपन करेंगे। कोई
सा भी लेट्स सपोज़ चलो पेंट टूल्स पे अगर
मिल जाए तो इस पे देख लेंगे।
क्या पॉसिबल है भाई? बताओ।
बताओ क्या पॉसिबल है?
इस पे देख लेते हैं। कुछ अगर मिलता है तो
हमें
पैसे वाली चीजें नहीं करेंगे भाई।
फिर से नेटवर्क का वो हो गया।
हम
हम हम
वब से हमें मिल नहीं पा रहा है। व अलब
वी आर नॉट गेटिंग द
टेक्स्ट एसपी इफ देयर इज़ ओपनिंग वेबसाइट
ही नहीं ओ टेक्स्ट एसपी हां टेक्स्ट एसपी
ओपन हो गई है। गुड। चलो ये ओपन हो गया
फाइनली। तो इसमें हम बेसिकली व्हाट वी विल
डू हम यहां पे इसको स्टार्ट करते हैं फिर
से। ठीक है? और यहां पे हम अ
यहां पे लॉग इन में टेस्ट डालेंगे। यहां
पे टेस्ट डालेंगे। कुछ भी डाल देंगे अभी
फिलहाल। लॉग इन करेंगे। ठीक है? यहां पे
हमने लॉग इन किया है। हमारे पास अब यहां
पे फ़िल्टर आए हुए हैं। तो हम यहां पे
फ़िल्टर को अब देखेंगे यहां पे स्टॉप कर
देंगे यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए। एंड हमारे
पास यहां पे कुछ डेटा पैकेट्स आए हैं। आप
देखेंगे यहां पे टेस्ट डेटा पैकेट्स को तो
आप देखेंगे यहां पे सोर्स और डेस्टिनेशन
दो तरह की चीजें यहां पे आपको देखने को
मिल रही है। राइट? सोर्स कहां से?
डेस्टिनेशन कहां से? ये आपको देखने को
यहां पे मिलती है कि सोर्स आईपी क्या है?
डेस्टिनेशन आईपी क्या है? यू विल फाइंड इट
हियर। तो अब इसमें हम आके देखेंगे यहां पे
कोई इस तरह की कोई हमारी लॉग इन डेटा कुछ
हमारे पास आई है क्या? सो वी विल सी दोज़
डेटा इफ देयर इज सम काइंड ऑफ डाटा पैकेट
एप्लीकेशन डाटा।
चलिए यहां पे हम इसको ना वो कर देते हैं।
एसटीटीp hटीtp को फ़्टर करते हैं। हां तो
ये रही http फ़िल्टर करा है हमने। ये लॉग
इन एएसपीx ये जो हमारा फर्स्ट जो ये
ट्रैफिक है ये एएसपी वाली ट्रैफिक है जो
हमने यहां पे देखी थी। राइट जो टेस्ट
एएसपी नॉट वन वेब पे जो हमने ओपन किया तो
यहां पे टेस्ट टेस्ट करके यूजरने पासवर्ड
डाला। तो हमारी जो ये http की ये
प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ हो रही है क्योंकि नॉन
सिक्योर है। आप देख सकते हैं तो एचटीdटीp
यूज़ हो रहा है। तो यहां पे एचटीडीटीp हमने
फिल्टर करा तो एचटीडी वही फिल्टर बाय
प्रोटोकॉल। तो हमें एचटीडीp के जितने भी
ट्रैफिक है वो आ गए। दो ट्रैफिक्स यहां पे
हैं। एक टेक्स्ट एचटीएमएल और एक यहां पे
लॉग इन वाला। तो हम लॉग इन वाले पे इस पे
जाते हैं। तो अब राइट क्लिक करेंगे। इस पे
हम फॉलो करेंगे यहां पे। एंड http स्ट्रीम
आएगी। एक टीसीp स्ट्रीम आएगी। दोनों को आप
चेक कर सकते हैं। एचटीdटीp स्ट्रीम पे आप
जाएंगे। तो यहां पे पूरी एचटीdटीp की पूरी
स्ट्रीम यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं रॉ
फॉर्मेट में एकदम ये इंक्रिप्टेड डेटा
नहीं है। तो रॉ फॉर्मेट में आपको यहां पे
पूरा क्लीन आपको शो कर रहा है। इसी के साथ
आप सेम मैं यहां पे एचटीटीp फिर से फ़्टर
कर देता हूं।
सेम अगर आप राइट क्लिक करके फॉलो करेंगे
एचटीसीपी स्ट्रीम तो आपको पूरी TCP
स्ट्रीम के अंदर भी सारी जो जानकारी है वो
यहां पे आपको दिखाता है। राइट? यहां पे आप
देखेंगे तो ये क्योंकि एचटीटीपी है तो
यहां हर कुछ हर कुछ जो है इंक्रिप्टेड
नहीं है। सारी चीजें अनइंक्रिप्टेड है। तो
आपको यहां पे रॉ फॉर्मेट में यहां पे आपको
देखने का मौका मिल जाता है। तो आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे अगर आप टेस्ट को फाइंड
करते हैं। लेट्स सी लेट्स फाइंड द टेस्ट
कहां-कहां है टेस्ट बाय ये रहा। तो
टेक्स्ट को आपने फाइंड किया तो आप देख
सकते हैं कि क्योंकि आप एचटीटीp इज़ नॉन
इंक्रिप्टेड प्रोटोकॉल। तो यहां पे प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में आपका यूजरनेम और पासवर्ड जो
है वह कैप्चर हो जाता है। य अगर आप https
ट्रैफिक कैप्चर कर रहे होते हैं तो यहां
पे यह इंक्रिप्टेड आपको मिलता है। यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड प्लेन टेक्स्ट में नहीं मिलती है।
सो वो सिक्योर एक कनेक्शन होता है। तो
आपको यहां पे आपको वो डाटा भी मिल गई है।
इसके अलावा भी आपको कुछ चीजें यहां पे
देखने को मिलेंगी। मैं यहां पे नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट कर देता हूं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हां। ठीक है। तो यहां पे आपको यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड कहां गया? हां। यहां पर आपको
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड जो है वह प्लेन टेक्स्ट
में देखने को मिल जाता है। तो यह पूरा
टीसीp स्ट्रीम का कमाल है जो कि आप फॉलो
करके टीसीp स्ट्रीम और या एचसीडीपी
स्ट्रीम को आप देख सकते हैं। राइट? चलिए
अब यहां पे मेन जो मुद्दा है उस पे आ जाते
हैं जो जिस पे हम वापस से कांसेप्ट पे
थोड़ा सा आ जाते हैं। फिर वापस से आएंगे।
तो
मैंने बस ये चीज समझाने के लिए एक पॉइंट
समझाने के लिए ये सब चीजें बताई है मैंने।
ठीक है? उसके बाद यहां पे आती है डिकोड एज
इफ नॉन स्टैंडर्ड ट्रैफिक यूसेस कस्टम
पोर्ट्स एग्जांपल एचटीटीp ओवर पोर्ट 880
राइट क्लिक एंड यूज़ द डिकोड एज टू मैनुअली
असाइन अ डसेक्टिंग प्रोटोकॉल तो आप राइट
क्लिक करके मैनुअली आप डिकोड एज करके आप
इसमें असाइन भी कर सकते हैं। जैसे कि
हमारे पास ट्रैफिक ये आई हुई है। राइट?
इसको हटाओ। ये ट्रैफिक आई हुई है। मैं आप
यहां एचटीडी
पी को यहां कैप्चर करता हूं। ये वाली चीज़
है। तो राइट क्लिक करके यहां पे आप डिकोड
एज पे यहां पे क्लिक करेंगे। यू विल जस्ट
क्लिक ऑन द डिकोड एज। ठीक है? तो यहां पे
आप एक मैनुअली जो है ना यहां पे आप असाइन
कर सकते हैं इसको। आप मैनुअली यहां पे आके
क्या कर सकते हैं? डिकोड एज फंक्शन को
डसेक्टिंग प्रोटोकॉल मैनुअली असाइन कर
सकते हैं। डसेक्टिंग प्रोटोकॉल मैंने
ऑलरेडी बताया कि किस तरह का प्रोटोकॉल आप
डिसाइड करना चाहते हैं। तो जैसे मेरे पास
ये है। यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं टीसीp
पोर्ट वैल्यू यहां पे दी हुई है। यहां पे
डिफ़ॉल्ट है नन है। फिलहाल के लिए यहां पे
करंट में यहां पे नन है। मतलब ये जो करंट
है इसका नन है। इस पे क्लिक करेंगे आप तो
यहां पे आपको पूरी डिट जो लिस्ट है वो
पूरी लिस्ट आ जाएगी। आप कौन सा इसको असाइन
करना चाहते हैं? किस तरीके का तो लाइक अ
लाइक इफ यू वांट टू असाइन इट लाइक डीएनएस
जो भी डसेक्टिंग प्रोटोकॉल्स है यू कैन
असाइन राइट तो आप
ये सिंपल प्रोटोकॉल असाइनमेंट कर सकते हैं
तो आप प्रोटोकॉल जो भी प्रोटोकॉल इसको
असाइन करना चाहें डक्टिंग के लिए आप इसको
असाइन कर सकते हैं। अगर कोई नॉन स्टैंडर्ड
प्रोटोकॉल पे यूटिलाइज हो रहा है तो पूरी
लिस्ट आपको आ जाएगी। यहां पे प्लस करने के
बाद आप यहां पे बेसिकली एक नया स्ट्रीम का
वो भी बना सकते हैं। बट स्टिल पहले जो था
उसी को आपको यूज़ करना है जो अभी फिलहाल के
लिए है। तो इस तरीके से आपका जो
फंक्शनैलिटी है वो यूज़ में आ जाता है। इस
तरीके से डिकोड एज की यूज़ केस होती है।
ठीक है?
ये तो समझ में आ गया होगा।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सर कैन हाउ कैन वी गेट दिस एचटीटीपी
रिकॉर्ड व्हेन ऑल द सेशन? ये एचटीटीपी ही
वेबसाइट है ब्रदर। दिस वेबसाइट इज़ अह जो
यहां पे हमने ओपन किया है ना यह HTTP
प्रोटोकॉल पे आया है। आप देखिए ना यह HTP
पीS पे नहीं है। यह नॉनसिक्योर है ना TST
pHP. Test sp.1.com
दिस इज़ ऑन HTTP प्रोटोकॉल नॉट https दैट्स
व्हाई यू आर एबल टू कैप्चर इन प्लेन
टेक्स्ट। https पे होगा तो आप प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में कैप्चर नहीं कर पाओगे। तो
यहां पे मैं आपको हैकिंग नहीं सिखा रहा
हूं फिलहाल इस चीज में कि कैसे आप
डाउनग्रेड एचटीपीएस को एचटीp करके आप इवन
एचटीपीs ट्रैफिक को भी प्लेन टेक्स्ट में
कई बार देख सकते हो। ये सब चीजें अभी नहीं
देख रहे हैं। अभी तो हम एसओसी के
पर्सपेक्टिव से हम देख रहे हैं। हम बस देख
रहे हैं कि कैसे वश को यूज़ हम करते हैं
फिल्टरिंग और इन सब चीजों के लिए। राइट?
वो चीज़ यहां पे आपकी हो रही है। तो ये आप
डिकोज एज फंक्शनैलिटी का आप यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। अगर डाइससेक्शन के बारे में मैंने
पहले ही बताया आपको। पिछले स्लाइड में
मैंने आपको बताया हुआ था डसेक्शन के बारे
में। ये
डसेक्टर्स क्या बेसिकली होते हैं? वार्षक
यही जो क्या करते हैं? डसेक्टर्स पास द रॉ
हेक्साइट्स एंड ट्रांसलेट देम इंटू ए
ह्यूमन रीडेबल फॉर्मेट। तो स्पेसिफिक
प्रोटोकॉल्स आप असाइन कर सकते हैं इसके
थ्रू। तो ये डसेक्टर्स होते हैं। अब देखिए
ये तो हो गया अपना। अब आगे की तरफ बढ़ते
हैं यहां पे। आगे की तरफ। फिर यहां पे हम
जब वायरशार्क ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस की बात
करते हैं तो वायर शार्क में ट्रैफिक्स को
आप एनालाइज़ कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? अब यह
ट्रैफिक एनालाइज करने के लिए आपको समझना
पड़ेगा कि बेसिकली दो
लोगों के बीच में जैसे ह्यूमंस दो ह्यूमंस
है तो मुझे इसका आंसर दीजिए। आप सबसे मैं
पूछता हूं जैसे आप और मैं बात करें या आप
और आपका दोस्त कोई बात कर रहा है। राइट?
तो दो ह्यूमंस
एक दूसरे से
बात
कैसे कर पाते हैं? किस किस चीज के थ्रू कर
पाते हैं? मुझे बताइए।
एक ह्यूमन दूसरे ह्यूमन से किस किस चीज के
थ्रू बात करता है?
बताइए
एवरीवन प्लीज आंसर इट।
हां सिंपल सा फंडा है। लैंग्वेज के थ्रू
बात करते हैं। राइट लैंग्वेज
राइट? लैंग्वेज के थ्रू बात कर सकते हैं।
उसी तरीके से कंप्यूटरटर्स के केस में दो
कंप्यूटरटर्स आपस में जब बात करते हैं तो
उनके उनके
बीच में एक टीसीपी हैंडशक इस्टैब्लिश होती
है। सॉरी उनके बीच में एक टीसीपी हैंडशक
हैंडशक एस्टैब्लिश होती है। एंड उसके बाद
वो बात कर पाते हैं। अब ये जो टीसीपी
हैंडशक इस्टैब्लिशमेंट होती है इसमें तीन
स्टेप्स होते हैं। तीन स्टेप्स। अब मैंने
पहले ही बोला यही चीज मैंने पहले बोला हुआ
है कि ये जो टीसीपी हैंडशेक है ये मैंने
पहले भी पढ़ा दिया आपको इसी सीरीज के अंदर
में आप लाइव के अंदर में आएंगे एसओसी के
लास्ट मतलब पहले की क्लासेस में जब आप
जाएंगे थोड़ा पीछे की तरफ में तो आपको
यहां पे देखने को मिल जाएगा
लेट मी शो यू गाइस
ये रहा डेटा पैकेट्स एंड थ्री वे हैंड चेक
ये क्लास 16 में मैंने आपको पूरी डिटेल
में बताई हुई है अगर आपको स्टिल थोड़ा
रिवाइज या कुछ करना हो तो इसको जाके वापस
से देख लीजिएगा। ठीक है? या नोट्स बनाए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] होंगे आपने तो
वेल एंड गुड। इसलिए मैंने बोला है बार-बार
कि नोट्स नोट्स नोट्स नोट्स इज़ वेरीेंट
गाइस। नोट्स बनाइए अपना खुद का बनाइए। दैट
विल बी वेरी वेरीरी यूज़फुल फॉर यू गाइस इन
फ्यूचर।
तो तीन स्टेप्स होते हैं। एक क्लाइंट
सर्वर से पहले बात करता है। सॉरी क्लाइंट
सर्वर से बात करता है। फिर सर्वर जो है
क्लाइंट को रिसोंड करता है और फिर क्लाइंट
जो है उसको एकनॉलेज करता है सर्वर से। तो
क्लाइंट सर्वर के बीच में जो बात होती है
यानी क्लाइंट जब इनिशिएट होती है कनेक्शन
मतलब कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश करने के पहले की
बात है ये कनेक्शन जब इनिशिएट होती है तो
क्लाइंट जो है वो सर्वर से सर्वर को सन
रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है एक सीन पैकेट जो होती
है वो भेजता है फिर सर्वर क्लाइंट के पास
एक सीन एसी के यानी उस सीन को उस सीन
पैकेट को एकनॉलेज करता है कि हां भैया ठीक
है सीन पैकेट हमारे पास आई है भैया ठीक है
ओके हम मैं रेडी हो रहा हूं अब और क्लाइंट
क्लाइंट जब और क्लाइंट को वह क्या भेजता
है भैया? सन एसी के पैकेट भेजता है। अब
क्लाइंट को जब सन एसीपी के पैकेट भेज देता
है तो क्लाइंट जो है सर्वर को बोलता है कि
अच्छा अच्छा कंफर्म करते हैं भाई कंफर्म
है। कंफर्म है मिल चुकी है मुझे आपकी एसी
के। यह हैंडशक कंफर्म होता है। अब हम जो
है कनेक्शन जो है इस्टैब्लिश कर लेते हैं
और बात वार्तालाप बातचीत जो है शुरू कर
देते हैं। तो ये तीन स्टेप होने के बाद ही
क्लाइंट और सर्वर के बीच में यानी दो
कंप्यूटर के बीच में बात होनी यानी
ट्रैफिक आदानप्रदान यानी कि सेंड रिसीव
होना स्टार्ट होता है। याद रखिएगा। यह तीन
प्रोसेस होती है। तो अब यहां पे इसमें
परफॉर्मेंस इशूज़ को आइडेंटिफाई करना है
हमें थोड़ा सा क्या होता है बेसिकली
परफॉर्मेंस इशज़ के इशू वो देख लेते हैं
थोड़ा। वायरशार्क ऑटोमेट्स नेटवर्क हेल्थ
डायग्नोस्टिक चेकक्स थ्रू TCP एक्सपर्ट
TCP एक्सपर्ट infox वाय शार्क सिर्फ
ट्रैफिक एनालाइजर या पैकेट मैनेजर नहीं
है। वायरशार्क नेटवर्क के हेल्थ को भी
डायग्नोस्टिक करने के लिए यूज़ में लिया
जाता है। जैसे नेटवर्क का हेल्थ क्या है?
नेटवर्क किस तरीके से नेटवर्क में चीजें
काम कर रही हैं। उसका हेल्थ क्या है वह भी
जो है बेसिकली इसमें वशा के थ्रू होता है।
वशा के थ्रू किया जाता है। अब इसमें किस
तरीके से होता है देखो पहले होती है
टीसीपी रीिट्रांसमिशंस इंडिकेट्स लॉस्ट
पैकेट्स ऑन द नेटवर्क वायर। कोई लॉस्ट
पैकेट है नेटवर्क वायर पे वो दिखाता है।
अकर्स व्हेन एन एसीके इज़ नॉट रिसीव्ड
बिफोर द रीिट्रांसमिशन टाइम्स एक्सपायर।
अगर कोई एकनॉलेजमेंट रिसीव नहीं हुआ है तो
एकनॉलेजमेंट रिसीव नहीं हुआ है।
एकनॉलेजमेंट किसके साइड से आती है? तो
एकनॉलेजमेंट क्लाइंट के साइड से आती है।
तो अगर एकनॉलेजमेंट ये कम्युनिकेशन के बीच
में ये स्टेप्स जो है तीनों तीनों के
तीनों मैंडेटरी स्टेप्स हैं। यानी कि
क्लाइंट सिम पैकेट भेजेगा ही भेजेगा।
सर्वर सीन एसी के पैकेट क्लाइंट को फिर
भेजेगा और क्लाइंट फिर एसी के भेजेगा। अगर
इन तीनों में से एक भी प्रोसेस एक भी
पर्टिकुलर स्टेप कंप्लीट नहीं होता है तो
वहां पर कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश नहीं होंगी और
क्लाइंट सर्वर के बीच में वार्तालाप
बातचीत शुरू नहीं हो पाएंगी और
कम्युनिकेशन नहीं हो पाएगा दो
कंप्यूटरटर्स के बीच में या दो दो किसी भी
नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस के बीच में तो याद
रखिएगा ये बात अब यहां पे आते हैं गाइस अब
यहां पे देखते हैं यहां पे एक इंटरेस्टिंग
एक और एक और इंटरेस्टिंग चीज कि अगर
एकनॉलेजमेंट इसी के रिसीव नहीं हुआ है
बिफोर दैट रीिट्रांसमिशन टाइमर एक्सपायर
रीट्रांसमिशन से पहले नहीं आया रहता है तो
उस केस में जो है पैकेट लॉस्ट समझा जाता
है कि पैकेट भाई लॉस हो गया बेचारा जब भी
पैकेट जो होता है जो भी पैकेट ट्रेवल कर
रही है टीसीपी डुप्लीकेट एसी के सिग्नल्स
दैट आउट ऑफ ऑर्डर और मिसिंग सेगमेंट्स
अराइव्ड एट द रिसीवर मतलब रिसीवर के पास
एक मिसिंग सेगमेंट आ चुका है फोर्सिंग इट
टू रिपीटेडली रिक्वेस्ट द मिसिंग सीक्वेंस
नंबर नंबर तो अब यह मिसिंग सीक्वेंस नंबर
जो है वह मांगेगा। रिसीवर जो है बार-बार
मिसिंग सीक्वेंस नंबर मांगेगा। क्योंकि यह
आपको टीसीपी डुप्लीकेट एसी के जब आपके
यहां पे आती है यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके का
आपको इशू आता है टीसीपी डुप्लीकेट एसी के
का। इसका मतलब है गड़बड़ है इस ट्रांसमिशन
में इस कम्युनिकेशन में कुछ ना कुछ गड़बड़
है। और यह गड़बड़ क्यों है? क्योंकि भैया
एक मिसिंग सेगमेंट आ चुकी है रिसीवर के
पास। रिसीवर जो आपका मतलब जो क्लाइंट है
उसके पास तो अब वो क्या करेगा कि बार-बार
एक मिसिंग सीक्वेंस नंबर ढूंढेगा जो
सीक्वेंस नंबर भेजी जाती है वो ढूंढेगा
सर्वज्ञता। ठीक है? बस सिंपल सिंपल सा
फंडा है।
ठीक है? TCP ज़ीरो विंडो इंडिकेट्स द
रिसीवर्स बफर इज़ कंप्लीटली फुल
इंस्ट्रक्टिंग द सेंडर टू पॉज डेटा
ट्रांसमिशन। अ क्लियर साइन ऑफ़ एप्लीकेशन
लेवल लेटेंसी। अब ये चीज जब हो जाएगी TCP
जीरो विंडो हो जाएगी। तो मतलब कि रिसीवर
का जो बफर है वो कंप्लीट फुल हो चुका है।
रिसीवर की डाटा एक्सेप्ट करने की क्षमता
खत्म हो चुकी है। भाई अब फुल हो चुका है।
अब वो बोलेगा सेंडर को भाई रुक जा थम जा
अब बंद करो इन ट्रांसमिशन को। अब मेरे
अंदर और पावर नहीं है डेटा को लेने की। तो
बंद करो इसको। यह भेजता है। तो इस तरीके
से हेल्थ चेकअप होती है एक ट्रांसमिशन की
नेटवर्क के अंदर में। सिक्योरिटी एनालिसिस
एंड टीएलएस डिस्क डिक्रिप्शन की अगर हम
बात करें तो उसमें दो तरीके की चीजें होती
हैं। डिटेक्टिंग स्कैनिंग और डिक्रिप्टिंग
एचटीटीपीएस ट्रैफिक जो अभी थोड़ी देर पहले
कुछ लोग बात कर रहे थे। अह उसके बारे में
ही हम बात कर रहे हैं यहां पे। डिटेक्टिंग
स्कैनिंग। मान लो कि कोई हैकर है वो एनमप
से स्कैन कर रहा है ओपन पोर्ट्स के लिए,
सर्विसेस के लिए, सर्विज के वर्जन के लिए।
तो ये एक मलिश स्कैन हो जाता है। जी। ठीक
है? तो मलेशियस नेटवर्क रिकॉग्नेंस जैसे
एनमप का स्कैन करना शोज़ अप एज हाई
वॉल्यूम्स ऑफ सीन पैकेट्स विदाउट
कंप्लीटिंग द थ्री वैशि। अब जब एनमैप की
जो स्कैनिंग वाली होती है ना जब एनमैप की
स्कैनिंग होती है। राइट? तो उसमें होता
क्या है एनमैप स्कैनिंग में कि हम जब एनमप
से किसी सिस्टम को स्कैन करते हैं पोर्ट्स
के लिए सर्विसेस के लिए ताकि ये देखने के
लिए कि कौन कोई वनरेबल सर्विसेस तो नहीं
इंस्टॉल्ड है उस सिस्टम पे सर्वर पे। कोई
ओपन पोर्ट तो नहीं है। तो वो जो रिक्वेस्ट
आती है ना वो थ्री वे हैंड से कंप्लीट
नहीं करती है। तो उस केस में क्या होता
है? बहुत हाई नंबर ऑफ सीन पैकेट भेजा जाता
है। सीन पैकेट्स वहां पे भेजे जाते हैं।
सीन पैकेट्स क्यों हाई नंबर भेजे जाते
हैं? क्योंकि पहला जो चीज होता है ना
क्लाइंट जो सर्वर को भेजता है वो सिन
पैकेट ही होता है। तो हम ही तो क्लाइंट
हैं। एंड मैप का यूज़ करके बहुत सारे सीन
पैकेट भेज रहे हैं। तो थ्री वैशि तो
कंप्लीट होना नहीं है। तो सीन पैकेट्स
बहुत सारा बाढ़ आ जाता है। बहुत सारे सीन
पैकेट्स दिखने लगेंगे। मतलब समझो कि कोई
ना कोई तरह का मशियस स्कैन कोई अटैकर आपके
नेटवर्क पे कर रहा है एनमप जैसे टूल का
यूज़ करके सीन एसीके फॉललोड बाय आर एसटी
ऐसा भी होता है और इनवैलिड फ्लैग
कॉम्बिनेशंस ठीक है मतलब ऐसा भी होगा कि
सीन एसीके आ रही है बट उसके बाद कनेक्शन
ड्रॉप हो जा रहा है यानी कि हो क्या रहा
है कि क्लाइंट ने सर्वर को सीन भेजा अब
सर्वर ने सीन एसीके भेजा उसके बाद तुरंत
क्लाइंट ने उसको बंद कर दिया कनेक्शन को
एर्रप्टली जो है मतलब ग्रेसफुली नहीं एकदम
से अचानक से कनेक्शन को क्लोज़ कर दिया। तो
यहां पे फिर वह एक इनवैलिड ट्रैफिक या
मलेशियस ट्रैफिक मानी जाएगी। अब
डिक्रिप्टिंग एचटीडीपी टीएलएस ट्रैफिक की
बात करें तो मॉडर्न वेब ट्रैफिक यूसेस द
टीएलएस इंक्रिप्शन। अब टीएलएस इंक्रिप्शन
गाइस जो है वो एसएसएल का ही सक्सेसर है।
ठीक है? जैसे पहले जो है ना पहले वो
एसएसएल [हंसी]
को यूज़ में लिया जाता था। मोस्टली। अभी जो
मॉडर्न वेब ट्रैफिक्स हैं वो टीएलएस को
यूज़ करते हैं। ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
सिक्योरिटी। एसएसएल वाज़ यूज़्ड अर्ली।
एसएसएल ओल्ड थिंग हो गई अब। तो अब यह जो
टीएलएस है अब इसमें क्या होता है? वशार्क
कैन डिक्रिप्ट सिक्योर स्ट्रीम्स इफ
प्रोवाइडेड विथ अ एसएसएल की लॉग फाइल
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल एक्सपोर्टेड बाय
ब्राउज़र्स क्रrome या firefox मैचिंग
प्राइवेट टीएलएस सेशन कीज़ अगेंस्ट
सिमेट्रिक पेलोड स्ट्रीम। तो मतलब वश के
अंदर यह भी ऑप्शन होता है कि एक फाइल होती
है एसएसएल की लॉग फाइल एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल। ठीक है? तो ये की फाइल जो होती
है ब्राउज़र्स से एक्सपोर्ट करके निकाला
जाता है। तो अगर आप ये कीलॉक फाइल एसएसएल
की फाइल्स को आप देते हैं आपके वायरशार्क
को तो वायरस शार्क इंक्रिप्टेड ट्रैफिक को
डिक्रिप्ट कर सकता है। बट यही बात है कि
यह जो है यह जो है दिस इज़ नॉट हैकिंग। याद
रखिएगा यह हैकिंग नहीं है। यहां पे तो आप
बेसिकली चाबी दे रहे हैं। ब्राउज़र के पास
ही चाबी होती है ट्रैफिक को डिक्रिप्ट
करने का। तो आप ब्राउज़र्स से एक्सपोर्ट
करके ट्रैफिक को डिक्रिप्ट करने के लिए
वायरस को चाबी दे रहे हैं कि ले भाई चाबी
से ताला खोल ले और मुझे दिखा दे अंदर क्या
है। वही चीज़ है यहां पे कि इस तरीके की
चीज़ भी लीगली की जा सकती है। क्योंकि मान
लो कोई इंक्रिप्टेड ट्रैफिक है। उसको कोई
पढ़ना चाहता है, रीड करना चाहता है। आप
एनालाइज़ करना चाहते हो नेटवर्क के हेल्थ
के लिए, नेटवर्क के मॉनिटरिंग के लिए तो
कैसे करोगे? तो वही की एसएसएल की लॉक फाइल
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल दो और उससे जो है आपका
काम हो जाएगा एंड आप उसको डिक्रिप्ट करके
उसको रीड आउट करके बस समझ सकते हैं। ठीक
है? यहां पे किसी ने पूछा है कि आई डिड
नॉट अंडरस्टैंड टीसीपी डुप्लीकेट एसीके।
देखो टीसीपी डुप्लीकेट एसीके का मतलब
सिंपल यहां पे था सिग्नल्स दैट आउट ऑफ
ऑर्डर और मिसिंग सेगमेंट्स अराइव्ड एट द
रिसीवर। मतलब कि एसीके कौन भेजता है?
क्लाइंट भेजता है सर्वर को। ठीक है? तो
यहां पर क्या हो रहा है?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
डुप्लीकेट एसी के मतलब कि क्लाइंट के पास
एक डुप्लीकेट एसी के आ गई है। इसका मतलब
यह हो जाता है कि कोई मिसिंग सेगमेंट आ
चुकी है। ऐसी सेगमेंट जो उसके पास क्लाइंट
के पास नहीं आनी चाहिए थी। क्लाइंट के पास
ऐसी कोई चीज आ गई है। सेगमेंट आ गई है जो
क्लाइंट के पास जो सर्वर से उसने अ
रिक्वेस्ट नहीं करा था और वो उसके पास आ
चुकी है। तो उस केस में क्या हो जाता है?
है डुप्लीकेट एसीके का यहां पे फॉर्मेशन
हो जाता है। डुप्लीकेट मतलब मिसिंग
सेगमेंट्स जो है वो अराइव कोई मिसिंग
सेगमेंट छोटा था वो मिस पहले मिसिंग था अब
वो आ चुका है क्लाइंट के पास तो वो जो है
डुप्लीकेट एसी के को यहां पे फॉर्म करता
है बेसिकली आउट ऑफ ऑर्डर है इस तरह का
मतलब कोई काम का नहीं है कुछ नहीं है वो आ
चुका है तो अब जब वो कोई भी डुप्लीकेट या
कोई भी आउट ऑफ ऑर्डर सेगमेंट आ जाता है या
मिसिंग सेगमेंट आ जाता है तो अब क्लाइंट
को उसका सीक्वेंस नंबर भी चाहिए क्योंकि
देखो ये जो सर्वर सीक्वेंस नंबर भेजता है
ना दूसरे स्टेप
ये पहले रिक्वेस्ट के अकॉर्डिंग ही भेजता
है। याद रखिएगा पहले रिक्वेस्ट में
सीक्वेंस नंबर यहां पे ज़ीरो है। दूसरे में
एकनॉलेज जो होती है वो एसी के वन हो जाती
है। एंड फिर से एक नया सीक्वेंस नंबर
स्टार्ट होता है इस तरीके से। तो यहां पे
ये पहले वाले रिक्वेस्ट का सीक्वेंस नंबर
होता है। अगर इसी के साथ कोई और चंक्स चला
गया है डेटा का मिसिंग सेगमेंट चला गया है
तो उसका सीक्वेंस नंबर कहां है? फिर
क्लाइंट बोलेगा भैया उसका सीक्वेंस नंबर
तो है नहीं। तो वो उस सीक्वेंस नंबर को
ढूंढेगा। उस सीक्वेंस नंबर को उसको फाइंड
करने की कोशिश करेगा। एंड उससे नेटवर्क
हेल्थ का पता चलेगा कि भैया यहां पे कुछ
ना कुछ कुछ मिसिंग सेगमेंट आ गई है या कुछ
आउट ऑफ बेकार डेटा जो है वो पहुंच गई है
क्लाइंट के पास जो बेसिकली जरूरत नहीं थी।
सिंपल।
ठीक है? समझ में आ गया? ये समझ में आ गया
होगा। आई थिंक चलिए
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] ये हो
गई। ये परफॉर्मेंस इशू आइडेंटिफिकेशन की
बात थी। अब यहां पर यह सारी चीजें तो
हमारी हो चुकी हैं। यह नॉर्मल सा पीपीटी
पर हम आ चुके हैं। अब मैं यहां पर
आता हूं
एक ट्राईक के रूम पे। बेसिकली यह प्रीमियम
रूम है व शार्क का। इस प्रीमियम रूम पे हम
आते हैं। ठीक है? यह प्रीमियम रूम है। अब
प्रीमियम रूम पे जब हम आएंगे तो यहां पे
कुछ यहां पे वॉक थ्रूज़ हैं। हम इस पे तो
जाएंगे। बट फिलहाल के लिए हम थोड़ा सा
इसको देखते हैं क्या है। हम ज्यादा इसमें
कुछ अभी नहीं करने वाले हैं। फिलहाल के
लिए हम देखते हैं। इसको मैं अभी बहुत
डिटेल में कवर करने वाला हूं क्योंकि
बेसिकली होता क्या है कि वाशक जैसी जो
टॉपिक्स है वो आप एक बार में कंप्लीट नहीं
कर सकते हैं। एक बार में एक सेशन में
कंप्लीट नहीं होगा। बहुत बड़ी टॉपिक है।
बहुत कुछ है इसके अंदर में। तो हम शायद
इसके लिए मल्टीपल क्लासेस लेकर आएंगे।
मल्टीपल क्लासेस में इसको कंप्लीट करेंगे।
तो फिलहाल के लिए आप देखेंगे यहां पे
बेसिकली
देखो यहां पे क्या है? मैं लैब मशीन को
स्टार्ट करता हूं। स्टार्ट लैब मशीन हम
यहां पेशा का थोड़ा सा बेसिक वो करेंगे बट
फिलहाल यहां पे इसको मैं नए टैब ओपन कर
लेते हैं।
ठीक है?
हां अब इस लैब मशीन के अंदर में
इंट्रोडक्शन में देखें तो यहां पे क्या
है? इंट्रोडक्शन में भैया यहां पे वशाक इज़
एन ओपन सोर्स। ये ठीक है। ठीक है। इट इज़
ओनली। अब यहां पे क्या है? नेविगेट द
नेविगेट ऑफ़ कॉन्फ़िगर वायरशा करेंगे।
इंस्पेक्ट पैकेट्स को इंस्पेक्ट करेंगे
एंड इनेशन डिस्कवर करेंगे। डिफरेंट लेयर्स
ऑफ़ टीसीpआईपी और डिस्प्ले फिल्टर को
अप्लाई करने का यहां पे सिस्टम है। अब
यहां पे इस वाले सिस्टम में क्या है? दो
दो फाइल्स हैं। एक http 1ph
pcp png pcp एनg और दूसरे फाइल जो है यहां
पे एक्सरसाइज डॉट pcp एनg ये फाइल है। तो
दोनों फाइल्स हैं। एक फाइल क्या है कि यू
कैन यूज़ दिस http 1 pcp एनg टू सिमुलेट द
एक्शंस। आप एक्शन को सेमुलेट करने के लिए
यूज़ में ले सकते हो। और अगर जब आपको अह
लाइक आंसर्स करने हैं क्वेश्चंस को तो
आपको एक्सरसाइज डॉट पिकैप एनg फाइल यूज़
करनी है। अब यहां पे देखना ये अ ओपन हो
गया। अब दो फाइल्स हैं यहां पे http वन
पिकैप एनजी और एक्सरसाइज पिक और यहां पे
ये वार्शक टूल भी आपका अवेलेबल है। तो
चलिए व्हिच फाइल इज़ यूज़्ड टू सेमुलेट द
स्क्रीनशॉट? तो सिमुलेट करने के लिए भाई
यह वाली फाइल है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है
इन्होंने ही बता दिया है। तो यह पूछ क्यों
रहे हैं? हो गया। व्हिच फाइल इज
व्हिच फाइल इज यूज्ड टू आंसर? तो ये वाली
फाइल है एक्सरसाइज पीक कैप। ठीक है? तो ये
हमने कर दिया। अब आते हैं टूल ओवर व्यू पे
अगर हम आते हैं तो यहां पे देखो टूल ओवर
व्यू में जीयू एंड डेटा के बारे में
इन्होंने बताया। तो इस पे ज्यादा हम फोकस
नहीं करेंगे क्योंकि ये कुछ नहीं है। यह
वायरशार्क का डेटा जीयूआई के बारे में वशक
के जो है वह बता रहे हैं। मैं अगर इसको
ओपन करूंगा तो यह इट विल ओपन द वशार्क। सो
लेट्स सी
यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से यह ओपन हुआ।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? ये ओपन हो गया यहां पे। एंड यहां
पे ये फाइल ओपन के लिए बोल रहा है। यहां
पे जो भी अ आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे जितने
भी नेटवर्क अपर्स हैं वो कोई भी यहां पे
इंटरफ़ेस जो है आपका वो काम नहीं कर रहा
है। वो यूज़ में नहीं है। क्योंकि अगर आप
इंटरफ़ेस काम कर रहा होता इनका तो आप
बेसिकली इनके नेटवर्क के अंदर में
कैप्चरिंग स्टार्ट कर देते हैं। इनके
नेटवर्क के ट्रैफिक को रीड करना शुरू कर
देते यहां से वाश से। तो इन्होंने ऑब्वियस
सी बात है यहां पे स्टार्ट करके ये देंगे
नहीं। सिंपल सा फंडा है यहां पे। ऑल
इंटरफ़ेस यहां पे देखेंगे तो आप सारे
इंटरफ़ेस शो कर रहा है जितने भी इंटरफ़ेस है
इनके। राइट? तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है। राइट?
तो यहां पे दो फाइल्स हैं। बस हमें उससे
मतलब है यहां पे। बट फिलहाल अगर वशा के
उसके बात करें तो इसमें इन्होंने बताया ये
टूल के बारे में कि किस तरीके से होता है।
तो ये इन्होंने बताया ये टूलबार होता है
बेसिकली। ये जो ऊपर के दो चीजें हैं ये जो
दो हैं फाइल, एडिट व्यू और ये आइकॉन्स
वाले ये टूलबार हैं आपके। और ये आपके
डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर बार है। तो बेसिकली यहां
पे डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर अ बार जो होता है वो
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर बार। ये ये वाला है।
अप्लाई अ डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर राइट? और यहां
पे ये कैप्चा फिल्टर का भी है। यहां पे इस
तरीके से ये डिस्प्ले फिल्टर है। डिस्प्ले
फिल्टर में जब आप ओपन कर लें जैसे कोई
फाइल को ओपन कर लेते हैं। मैं यहां पे इस
फाइल को ओपन कर लेता हूं। लाइक
एचटीp कैप एनg
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं के अंदर में। लेट्स
ओपन इट। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। सो यहां पे ओपन हो चुकी है यहां पे।
मैं इसको थोड़ा सा
ज़ूम कर देता हूं। इफ इट इज़ ज़ूमिंग इन।
नहीं तो फिर इतना पे रहने देंगे। कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है।
ठीक है? ठीक है। तो यहां पे ये ओपन हो
चुकी है। चलिए अच्छी बात है। अब यहां पे
आप देख सकते हैं नीचे का। अब लोडिंग पिकैप
फाइल तो आप लोड कर लेंगे जैसे एचटीडीपी वन
को हमने यहां पे लोड कर लिया है यहां पे।
ठीक है? तो यहां पे बेसिकली अ पैकेट की
डिटेल्स होते हैं। जैसे ये ट्रांसमिशन
कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल आपको दिख रहा हो। मैं
इसको थोड़ा सा छोटा करता हूं। अगर यह हो
जाए तो यहां से ये एक्सटेंड हो रहा है
क्या ये? बहुत ही स्लो काम करेगा यह। वैसे
तो अभी बट यहां पे ये सारे पैकेट्स हैं।
ये सारे ट्रैफिक हैं। यहां पे लेफ्ट साइड
में जो नीचे पैनल है यह आपका पैकेट की
डिटेल है। और ये जो है वो पैकेट बाइट्स के
अंदर में पैकेट की बाइट्स की बाइट्स है
उसकी इनेशन है। तो ये पूरे पैकेट का डिटेल
है। ये पैकेट के बाइट्स के बारे में यहां
पे इनेशन है। ठीक है? उसी तरीके से पैकेट
लिस्ट आप देख सकते हैं ये सब कुछ डिटेल
में कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। उसके बाद ये
कलरिंग पैकेट का एक ऑप्शन होता है यहां पे
आपके लाइक कलराइज जैसे कलरिंग आप पैकेट को
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। इसको कॉन्फ़िगर कर सकते
हैं। ठीक है? कलरिंग रूल्स पे आप जाके। तो
बेसिकली होता क्या है कि जैसे व्यू पे
जाते हैं आप यहां पे इसके मेन्यू में व्यू
पे।
ठीक है? इसको हम यूज़ वैसे कर देंगे बाद
में। यहां पे बट ठीक है। यहां पे कलरिंग
रूल्स यहां पे आते हैं, ऑप्शन आते हैं। तो
आप कलरिंग रूल्स अ लाइक या कलराइज़ पैकेट
लिस्ट कर सकते हैं। जैसे कलराइज़ पैकेट
लिस्ट आप करेंगे। मैं यहां पे क्लिक करता
हूं। जस्ट अ सेकंड।
तो ये कलराइज था तो आपको कलर में दिख रहे
थे। अब यह हट चुका है। तो बिल्कुल रॉ आपको
दिख रहा है। उसी तरीके से यहां पर व्यू पर
चलके
सॉरी लेट्स गो ऑन व्यू।
इट्स वर्किंग क्वाइट स्लो। मुझे खुद के ही
लगता है सिस्टम पर करना होगा। और यहां पर
वापस से आप कलराइज कर लेते हैं कलराइज
पैकेट लिस्ट। तो ये वापस से कलर्ड पैकेट्स
के फॉर्म में मतलब अलग-अलग कलर के टाइप
में दिखना शुरू हो जाएंगे। ठीक है? तो अभी
जस्ट वेट।
काफी स्लो काम कर रहा है यह इनका।
हां। तो कलराइज़ कर दिया मैंने। तो अब ये
थोड़ा कलर्ड पैकेट में शो कर दिया जाएगा।
वैसे मैं इस पे भी आपको वैसे दिखा सकता
हूं जो हमारी जो खुद की यहां पे ट्रैफिक
कैप्चा हमने करी थी।
फिल्टर हटा देते हैं यहां पर। यह जो आपको
दिख रहा है यहां पर तो यह जैसे व्यू पर आप
जाओगे यहां पर तो यहां पर दिख रहा है
कलराइज पैकेट लिस्ट। अब मैं कलराइज पैकेट
लिस्ट पे क्लिक करूंगा। हटा दूंगा तो ये
बिल्कुल रॉ दिखने लगता है। बिल्कुल मतलब
नॉन कॉलर जो होती है वो हो जाएगा। फिर
व्यू पे आप जाएंगे। यहां पे कलराइज कर
देंगे तो ये बेसिकली कलराइज्ड आपको शो
करेगा। थोड़ा कलरफुल आपको जो है वो शो
करने लगता है। राइट? इस तरीके के ऑप्शंस
इसमें होते हैं। इसके
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बाद
इसके अलावा अब हम देखते हैं कुछ आगे की
तरफ बढ़ते हैं।
आप खुद के कलर पैटर्न्स भी बना सकते हैं।
जैसे कि अगर आप चाहें तो मैं व्यू पे
जाऊंगा तो यहां पे कलर कलरिंग रूल्स जो है
वो आते हैं आपको। कलरिंग रूल्स एंड कलराइज
कन्वर्ज़ंस आते हैं। तो कलरिंग रूल्स पे आप
जाएंगे तो यहां पे आपको अलग-अलग कलरिंग
रूल्स देखने को मिलेंगे। आप खुद का यहां
पे कलरिंग रूल्स सेटअप कर सकते। आई थिंक
अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मुझे बताइए अभी नेटवर्क इशू अब शायद सही
हो जाएगी। सो लेट मी नो इफ द नेटवर्क इशू
इज गुड नाउ
इफ द नेटवर्क इश इशू इज़ गुड नाउ
अब बफर नहीं हो रहा होगा शायद अब अब बताइए
मुझे अब बफर अभी भी हो रहा है क्या
इट्स ओके नाउ हां ये मेरे सिस्टम का शायद
कुछ इशू हो रहा है पता नहीं ये बहुत
पुराना लैपटॉप हो गया तो इसका एनआई सी
नेटवर्क इंटरफेस कार्ड सही से काम नहीं कर
रहा लग रहा है मुझे वाईफाई के साथ कुछ
देखना पड़ेगा इसका कुछ
या तो
या तो इसको चेंज करना पड़ेगा अब सिस्टम को
रैम की वजह से अ जितने भी लैपटॉप्स हैं
इतने महंगे हो गए हैं चाहे Windows बेस्ड
लैपटॉप हो MacBook तो खैर महंगा हो ही गया
है कि एक ₹15 लाख महंगा हो गया है कि बहुत
सारे लोग अफोर्ड नहीं कर पा रहे हैं आज के
टाइम में गेमिंग लैपटॉप्स क्योंकि जो
गेमिंग लैपटॉप्स पहले ₹1 लाख की थी वो अब
ढाई-ाई लाख के 2 लाख के हो चुके हैं। डबल
डबल प्राइसेस भी बढ़ गए हैं। रैम की वजह
से, रैम शॉर्टेज की वजह से। ऐसा भी हुआ।
आप लोगों में से कई लोगों ने नोटिस करा
होगा या जानते भी होंगे। पता चला भी होगा
शायद। राइट? तो जिन भी लोगों को लैपटॉप
लैपटॉप वगैरह लेना हो उनके पास एक बहुत
अच्छी अपॉर्चुनिटी आएगी बिग बिलियन डे का।
बहुत सितंबर में हर साल होता है बिग
बिलियन डे। को पता है सेप्टेंबर मिड या
एंड में शायद आती है। उस समय अगर आपको
अच्छा डिस्काउंट किसी भी ब्रांड के तरफ से
किसी भी लैपटॉप अच्छे लैपटॉप पे मिल रहा
हो तो आई वुड रिकमेंड यू टू टेक द लैपटॉप
टू बाय द लैपटॉप सॉरी क्योंकि आने वाले
टाइम में रैम शॉर्टेज की वजह से हो सकता
है कि प्राइसेस और ज्यादा बढ़ जाए
लैपटॉप्स के। फिर जो चीज अभी जो चीज
80,000 की ₹1.5 लाख की हो गई थी वो 1.5
लाख से 2 लाख हो सकती है। तो अगर आपके पास
एक अच्छी अपॉर्चुनिटी हो तो डेफिनेटली गो
अहेड इन द अ
बिग बिलियन डे सेल जब सेल आती है या ग्रेट
ग्रेट इंडिया सेल होती है Amazon वगैरह की
उसमें आप जा सकते हैं। उसमें आप ले सकते
हैं। आपके पास चांस रहेगा एक। ठीक है?
चलिए अगेन वापस से टॉपिक पे आ जाते हैं
भैया हम।
ठीक है? तो ये ट्रैफिक स्नेफिंग यहां से
आप स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं। जैसे ही ब्लू पे
आप क्लिक करेंगे यहां पे। अगेन जो है यहां
पे आप सेव भी सेव कर सकते हैं इस ऑलरेडी
इस कैप्चरर्ड फाइल को या तो कंटिन्यू
विदाउट सेविंग कर सकते हैं। तो वापस से एक
नया फ्रेश
पैकेट कैप्चरिंग जो है वो स्टार्ट हो
जाएगी। लाइव आप देख सकते हैं जब तक आप
इसको स्टॉप नहीं करेंगे ये चलता ही रहेगा।
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे इट्स ऑनगोइंग
ऑनगोइंग। ये चलता है। जो भी चीज़ आप करोगे
ना आप ब्राउज़र में कुछ कर रहे हो कोई
एप्लीकेशन हर चीज़ लाइक ब्राउज़र में जो भी
कनेक्टिविटी कनेक्शन बना रहे हो वो सब
चीजें जो है वो आपकी यहां पे कैप्चर होनी
स्टार्ट हो जाएंगी रियल टाइम में। यह
स्निफिंग यह आपका यहां पे स्निफ हो रहा
है। ट्रैफिक जो है वो स्निफिंग चल रही है।
राइट? अब देखिए यहां पे पिककैप फाइल्स जो
भी ये जो पैकेट्स आपको कैप्चर हो रहे हैं
ना मैं आपको मान लो यहां पे स्टॉप कर रहा
हूं। मैंने स्टॉप किया। अब मैं स्टॉप
करूंगा तो यहां पे आपको ऑप्शन मिलेगा
अलग-अलग तरह के। यहां पे सेव दिस कैप्चर
फाइल का ऑप्शन मिलेगा। क्लोज ऑप्शन
मिलेगा। रीलोड मिलेगा। तो मैं अगर सेव
वाला क्लिक करूंगा ना सेव दिस कैप्चर
फाइल। तो जब मैं सेव पे क्लिक करूंगा तो
वायरशार्क का अपना एक एक्सटेंशन होता है
जिसमें कैप्चरर्ड जो ट्रैफिक है जिसको आप
बाद में फिर फदर फ्यूचर में एनालिसिस के
लिए यूज कर सकते हैं या यहां से कैप्चर
ट्रैफिक को उठाइए और किसी और सिस्टम पे
वायर शार्प के अंदर उसको इंपोर्ट करके
उसको आप एनालाइज करना शुरू कर सकते हैं।
तो इनका एक अपना एक्सटेंशन होता है जो कि
पीकैप एनg या पीकैप एक्सटेंशन होता है
जिसमें कि ये सेव करते हैं। आप पीcaप या
pक एनg में सेव कर सकते हैं। तो यह उसी
नाम से सेव होता है। उसी एक्सटेंशन के साथ
सेव होता है। तो उन पिककैप फाइल्स को आप
मर्ज भी कर सकते हैं। लाइक वायरस कैन
कंबाइन टू पिककैप फाइल्स इनू वन सिंगल
फाइल। यानी दो तरह दो कैप्चरर्ड फाइल को
ट्रैफिक कैप्चरर्ड फाइल को आप एक फाइल में
मर्ज कर सकते हैं। इसके लिए कुछ नहीं करना
है। सिंपल आपको फाइल में जाना है। यहां पे
मर्ज का एक ऑप्शन आपको देखने को मिलेगा।
यह मर्ज मर्ज पे आप जाएंगे तो यहां पे सेव
पैकेट्स बिफोर मर्जिंग। आपको इस बोलेगा कि
पैकेट टेंपरेरी कैप्चर फाइल कांट बी मर्ज।
ये टेंपरेरी। तो इसको सेव करना पड़ेगा।
फिर दो आप कैप्चर फाइल को आप बेसिकली क्या
कर सकते हैं? मर्ज कर सकते हैं इसके साथ
में। ठीक है? वंस यू क्लिक ओपन इट विल
मर्ज द एकिस्टिंग पिकअप फाइल विद द चूज़न
एंड क्रिएट अ न्यू पिकअप फाइल। मतलब दो
फाइल्स को मिला के एक फाइल यहां पे बना
देगा। आपको यहां पे जिफ देखना है। तो ये
जिफ देख लीजिए। कुछ इस तरीके से यह होता
है। यह आपको जिफ दिखा रहे हैं। कुछ इस
तरीके से फाइल मर्ज करेंगे। तो यहां पे एक
पिक का फाइल आपने सेलेक्ट किया। यहां पे आ
चुकी है यहां पे। और करंट जो आपकी फाइल है
यहां पर
सेव
मजेस यहां पर सेव कर सकते हो। उसके बाद
मर्ज का सेव कर देंगे। तो आपका ये मर्ज
वाला फाइल सेव हो जाएगा। अ व्यू फाइल
डिटेल्स। अब मान लो नोइंग द फाइल डिटेल्स
इज़ हेल्पफुल। स्पेशली व्हेन वर्किंग विथ
मल्टीपल पिककैप फाइल्स। समटाइम्स यू नीड
टू नो द एंड रिकॉल द फाइल डिटेल्स सच ऐश
कैप्चर टाइम, कैप्चर फाइल कमेंट। ये सारी
चीजें जो है आप देख सकते हैं। तो यू कैन
व्यू द डिटेल्स बाय फॉलोइंग स्टैटिस्टिक्स
अह कैप्चर फाइल प्रॉपर्टीज़ बाय क्लिकिंग
ऑन द पीकैप आइकॉन लोकेटेड ऑन द लेफ्ट
बॉटम। लेफ्ट बॉटम एक पिककैप आइकॉन होता
है। उस पे आप क्लिक करके आप उसकी
प्रॉपर्टीज देख सकते हो। जैसे कि यहां पे
आप देख सकते हो। यह कुछ इस तरीके की है।
मैं आपको वापस से दिखा देता हूं। यहां पे
नीचे की तरफ आपको दिखेगा।
यहां पर यह देखिए यहां पर
H3PO मान लो यहां पे है तो
ये जो नीचे की तरफ में ये जो आइकॉन होता
है उसकी बात हो रही है यहां पे जैसे यहां
पे ये जो ये छोटा सा आइकॉन है ना ये छोटा
जैसे ये कोई फाइल है तो इस पे क्लिक
करेंगे ये सबसे नीचे में लेफ्ट लेफ्ट में
बॉटम में यहां पे यहां पे कोने में इस पे
क्लिक करेंगे तो इस पूरी इस फाइल की
डिटेल्स आपको शो करता तो फाइल का नाम
बेसिकली क्या है? कितनी लेंथ का 13 MB का
है? हैश वैल्यू इसकी 256 एसएसए वन क्या
है? फॉर्मेट क्या है? तो पीक कैप एनजी
फाइल है आपकी वारश की।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ठीक है? तो
इनकैप्सुलेशन इथरनेट का यूज़ हो रहा है
इनकैप्चुलेशन इनकैप्सुलेशन करने के लिए।
कैप्चर मोड क्या है भैया? तो कैप्चर मोड
के लिए आपका वही हार्डवेयर आपका जो
प्रोसेसर है वो यूज़ हुआ है। ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम आपकी यूज़ हुई है। एप्लीकेशन अ डंप
पिक। ठीक है? डंप कैप या डंप पिक जो भी है
वो यूज़ में लिया जा रहा है। इंटरफ़ेस कौन
सा यूज़ हो रहा है भैया? तो Wi-Fi इंटरफ़ेस
यूज़ हो रही है आपकी। इथर लिंक टाइप है
आपका एंड Wi-Fi का यूज़ यहां पे लिया जा
रहा है। ठीक है? उसके बाद स्टैटिस्टिक्स
शो करेगा सारा कि लाइक पैकेट्स कितने
कैप्चर्ड हुए हैं टोटल। डिस्प्ले कितने
हुए हैं? तो टोटल 9000 पैकेट्स कैप्चर हुए
हैं एंड डिस्प्लेड 952 डिस्प्लेड हुए हैं।
कितने बाइट्स हुए हैं? एवरेज क्या है? सब
कुछ सब कुछ स्पीड वगैरह सब कुछ आपको बताया
बेसिकली। तो एवरीथिंग इज़ बीइंग यहां पे
टोल्ड बाय दीज़ डिटेल्स सब कुछ। तो यहां पे
यूज़ द एक्सरसाइज पिक फाइल टू आंसर द रीड द
कैप्चर फाइल कमेंट्स। व्हाट इज़ द फ्लैग?
कैप्चर फाइल कैप्चर फाइल कमेंट्स। अब यहां
पे कैप्चर फाइल कमेंट्स का यहां पे वही
है। यह हमने ऊपर में देखा था यहां पे। अ
यह कैप्चर फाइल कमेंट्स।
यह कमेंट्स यहां पर शो कर रहे हैं। यहां
पर पैकेट कमेंट्स भी शो करते हैं। जैसे
अगर कोई पैकेट कमेंट है इस पे नीचे आएंगे
तो यहां पे आपको ये शो करेगा फिलहाल के
लिए। तो वो टास्क में दिखा रहे हैं कि
भैया उसको स्टार्ट करो जो दूसरा वाला था
ना उसको स्टार्ट करो। तो मैं मान लीजिए
एक्सरसाइज pcpn अब इसको स्टार्ट करो। अब
यहां पे ये पैकेट खुल रहा है यहां पे
एक्सरसाइज कैपng राइट? अब इसको इसकी
प्रॉपर्टी आपको देखनी पड़ेगी। कमेंट्स
हमें देखना है। राइट? तो अब इसकी
प्रॉपर्टी कैसे देखेंगे? तो यहां पे ये
वाली बॉटम लेफ्ट में क्लिक करेंगे तो यहां
पे पूरी अब यहां पे फाइल कैप्चर कमेंट्स
यहां पे आ रहा है। यहां पे देख रहे हो
वहां पे कैप्चर फाइल कमेंट्स। इसमें सारी
इस फाइल इस कैप्चरर्ड फाइल की जो पिकिका
फाइल है उसकी पूरी डिटेल्स है इस फाइल के
बारे में और नीचे में यहां पे कैप्चर फाइल
कमेंट्स है। अब इसी में आपका यहां पे
फ्लैग लिखा हुआ है। ट्राई हैक मी व शार्क
डेमो करके यहां पे। बस यही आपको डाल देना
है यहां पे।
राइट?
हो गया। व्हाट इज द टोटल नंबर ऑफ़ पैकेट्स?
टोटल नंबर ऑफ पैकेट्स कितने हैं भैया? तो
आप यहां पे देख सकते हैं टोटल पैकेट्स
कितने पैकेट्स हैं? 58 620 तो ये हमारे
टोटल पैकेट्स हैं। यहां पे आप टोटल पैकेट
डाल दीजिए। 58 58 कितने भाई? 58 620
620 हमने डाल दिया। अब यहां पर है व्हाट
इज़ द एसए 256 हैश वैल्यू ऑफ़ द कैप्चर
फाइल? तो एसए 256 हैश वैल्यू क्या है
भैया? तो यह रही हमारी हैश वैल्यू। एसए
सॉरी यह रही हमारी एसए
256 कॉपी किया मैंने यहां पर।
यहां पर पेस्ट कर दिया। यह हमारी ऐसे हो
गई। तो ऐसे करके ये चीजें हम बना। ये बहुत
ही इजी चीजें होती हैं। अगर आपको
कांसेप्ट्स पता है तो ये लैब्स और ये जो
वॉक थ्रू है ये बहुत आसान हो जाएंगे। ये
लैब्स आप आराम से सॉल्व कर सकते हैं।
हालांकि ये जो लैब है पर्टिकुलर लैब है।
ये प्रीमियम रूम है वशाक बेसिक्स का। मैं
एक रिकमेंड आप सबको एक रिकमेंडेशन करूंगा
सब सभी लोगों को कि नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक
बेसिक्स इस लैब को आप सभी लोग कंप्लीट
करेंगे। इट्स वेरी वेरीेंट नेटवर्क
ट्रैफिक का बेसिक्स आपको पूरा एक हैंड्स
ऑन आपको थोड़ा करना है। इट्स वेरीेंट। यह
फ्री रूम है। आप जाके ट्राईक मी पे सर्च
कर सकते हैं। नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक बेसिक्स 60
मिनट का। इसको आप कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा।
प्रीमियम रूम्स तो हम सब कंप्लीट करेंगे
ही। तो उसका कोई टेंशन आपको लेना नहीं है।
तो यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए ये हमने ये
सिंपल सा ये जो पहला हमारा था ये हमने
कंप्लीट कर लिया। अब अब पैकेट डाइससेक्शंस
की बात आ रही है। तो पैकेट डाइससेक्शन का
मतलब क्या होता है? पैकेट डाइससेक्शन इज़
आल्सो नोन ऐज़ प्रोटोकॉल डाइससेक्शंस।
प्रोटोकॉल डाइससेक्शंस होता है ये व्हिच
इन्वेस्टिगेट्स पैकेट्स डिटेल्स बाय
डिकोडिंग अवेलेबल प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड फिल्स।
जो भी अवेलेबल प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड फिल्स हैं
उनको डिकोड करके जो है पैकेट को
इन्वेस्टिगेट किया जाता है। वायरशार्क
सपोर्ट्स अ लॉन्ग लिस्ट ऑफ़ प्रोटोकॉल्स
फॉर डाइससेक्शंस एंड यू कैन आल्सो राइट ओन
डसेक्शंस स्क्रिप्ट्स। तो वायरशार्क जो है
बहुत लंबी डसेक्शन प्रोटोकॉल्स को सपोर्ट
करता है। एंड बहुत यहां पे आप इसकी पूरी
वो लिस्ट आप देख सकते हैं।
तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आप देखें
यहां पे ये डसेक्टर का मतलब Redmi फाइल है
यहां पे बेसिकली। तो आप ये Redmi फाइल देख
के आप इसको पढ़ सकते हैं थोड़ा सा। इसमें यह
हालांकि डसेक्टर की बहुत लंबी चौड़ी रीडमी
फाइल है। आप इसको पढ़ लीजिएगा। हालांकि हम
इस पर अभी फिलहाल नहीं जा रहे हैं। दिस
सेक्शन कवर्स हाउ वार्शक यूज़ ओएसआई लेयर
टू ब्रेक डाउन पैकेट्स एंड हाउ टू यूज़
दीज़ लेयर्स फॉर एनालिसिस इट। तो ओएसआई
लेयर्स का यूज़ कैसे करता है? पैकेट्स को
ब्रेकडाउन करने के लिए वशार्क इट इज़
एक्सपेक्टेड दैट यू ऑलरेडी हैव बैकग्राउंड
नॉलेज ऑफ़ द ओएसआई मॉडल एंड हाउ इट वर्क्स।
अब देखो यहां पे चीजें क्या होती है?
धीरे-धीरे जब हम अब खत्म होने की तरफ
बढ़ेंगे। कॉम्प्लेक्स थोड़ी चीजें होंगी।
कॉम्प्लेक्स चीजें उन्हीं को कॉम्प्लेक्स
नहीं लगेगा जिन्होंने ऑलरेडी बेसिक्स
कांसेप्ट सारे जो पहले मैंने कराए थे
ओएसआई नेटवर्किंग टीसीपी वो सब करे थे। अब
बताओ जिसने ओएसआई मॉडल वाला कांसेप्ट वाले
क्लास उतनी मजे से नहीं करे हो या नहीं
उतना सोचा होगा अरे क्या ही ज्यादा होगी
इसकी उसका ये कहां से हो पाएगा और ये चीज
नहीं करोगे फिर आपका वार्षक खत्म हो जाएगा
वार्षक छूट जाएगी फिर तो पूरा एसओसी का
गड़बड़ हो गया ना कबाड़ा तो मैंने पहले ही
जब ये सीरीज स्टार्ट करी थी मैंने पहले ही
बोला था कि यह एक जॉब रेडी सीरीज है तो यू
नीड टू गिव टाइम यू नीड टू फॉलो व्हाट आई
एम सेइंग यू डोंट नीड नीड टू गो व्हाट योर
हार्ट और माइंड इज़ सेइंग। यू यू नीड यू
डोंट हैव टू फॉलो योर ओन हार्ट और माइंड।
फिलहाल के लिए स्टार्ट जब तक यह खत्म नहीं
हुआ। मेरा कहना मानना है और उन चीजों को
करना है। अब जिन्होंने नहीं करा अभी भी
चांस है पहले के वीडियोस को आप देख सकते
हैं जो जो कवर करी है। दैट्स इट। बस इतना
ही मैं बोलूंगा। ठीक है? अब पैकेट डिटेल्स
में यू कैन क्लिक ऑन द पैकेट इन द पैकेट
लिस्ट पेन। यहां पर आप पैकेट पर क्लिक कर
सकते हैं और उसकी डिटेल्स आ जाती हैं। ठीक
है? और डबल क्लिक विल ओपन डिटेल्स इन न्यू
विंडो। पैकेट कंसिस्ट ऑफ फाइव टू सेवन
लेयर्स बेस्ड ऑन द ओएसआई मॉडल। हर पैकेट
का एक लेयर होता है। फाइव टू सेवन लेयर
ओएसआई मॉडल के बेसिस पे। जैसे कोई एक
पैकेट है मान लो मेरे पास http कुछ है
क्या मेरे पास? देखते हैं। http में है
शायद। हां।txt
ठीक है। ये वाला। अब मान लो ये एक पैकेट
है। तो ये ओएसआई लेयर की के बेसिस पे क्या
होता है? यह लेयर्स होते हैं। 1 2 3 4 5
छह लेयर्स यहां पे यहां पे दिए गए हैं। तो
एसआई मॉडल के अकॉर्डिंग ये लेयर्स होते
हैं। जिसमें कि आपका वही नेटवर्क लेयर
आपका ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर ये सब चीजें जो
ओएसआई में आप सीखते हैं ना वही लेयर्स
यहां पे आपके डिफाइंड होते हैं। अब इन्हीं
लेयर्स को आपको यूज़ करके आपको चीजों को
समझना है। आप क्लिक करेंगे तो उसकी पूरी
डिटेल आएगी। ईच टाइम यू क्लिक अ डिटेल। इट
विल हाईलाइट द कॉस्पोंडिंग पार्ट इन द
पैकेट बाइट्स सेगमेंट। जब भी आप इसको में
से किसी भी उस पे क्लिक करते हैं जैसे मान
लो मैं फ्रेम पे करता हूं या इथरनेट पे
मान लो मैं मान लो मैं इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल
आईपी पे क्लिक करता हूं आईपी पे क्लिक
करूंगा तो इसकी डिटेल्स राइट पैनल में
यहां पे मुझे शो करेंगी यहां पे
ठीक है आईपी पे क्लिक तो इसकी डिटेल्स अब
मैं लाइन बेस्ड टेक्स्ट डेटा पे करता हूं
तो मैं इस पे क्लिक करूंगा तो ये उसको
हाईलाइट करेंगे लाइन बेस्ड जो भी डेटा है
उसको यहां पे हाईलाइट करेंगी तो वो सारी
चीजें राइट पैनल में यहां पे पैकेट बाइट
पैनल में यहां पे आपको शो करती हैं। ठीक
है? व्हेन वी कैन सी अ सेवन डिस्टिंक्ट
लेयर्स ऑफ द पैकेट फ्रेम पैकेट सोर्स
सोर्स मैक आईपी प्रोटोकॉल प्रोटोकॉल
लेयर्स ये सारी चीजें एप्लीकेशन डेटा बिलो
विल द तो अब ये फ्रेम लेयर होता है एक
हमारा तो ये फ्रेम लेयर ये फिजिकल लेयर को
डिनोट करता है आपका ओएसआई मॉडल का दूसरा
जो होता है वो डेटा लिंक लेयर ओएसi मॉडल
का डिनोट करता है। तीसरा जो होता है
नेटवर्क लेयर को डिनोट करता है आपके ओएसआई
मॉडल का। चौथा जो आपका होता है
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर को डिनोट करता है। ठीक
है? उसके बाद पांचवा आपका होता है यहां पे
एप्लीकेशन लेयर को डिनोट करता है और जो
स्पेसिफिक डेटा होती है उसी का एक्सटेंशन
यहां पे नेक्स्ट वाला लेयर होता है। कुछ
इस तरीके से ये काम करती है। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे आप देख सकते हो यहां पे क्वेश्चंस
उसी तरीके से बेस्ड है यहां पे एक्सरसाइज
पीएजी में कि आप पैकेट नंबर 38 को देखिए।
व्हिच मार्कअप लैंग्वेज इज़ यूज्ड अंडर द
एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल? तो एचटीटीपी
प्रोटोकॉल में कौन सी मार्कअप लैंग्वेज
यूज़ हुई है? ये आपका क्वेश्चन है। तो ये
सिंपल सा फंडा है कि यहां पे अब आपको
पैकेट को रीड करना है। पैकेट को देखना है।
ये हम थोड़ा अब नेक्स्ट सेशंस में हम इसको
कंप्लीट करेंगे। बट वैसे मैं ओवरव्यू दे
देता हूं थोड़ा। जैसे मान लो ये 38 नंबर है
पैकेट। तो इस पे मैंने क्लिक किया। यहां
पे मैंने यहां पे क्लिक किया। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे क्लिक किया तो आप देख सकते हैं कि
एचटीटीp यहां पे क्या लिखा हुआ आ रहा है
कि व्हिच मार्कअप लैंग्वेज यूज़ अंडर द
एचटीडीटीp प्रोटोकॉल? तो एचटीटीp
प्रोटोकॉल के अंदर में ये एचटीडीटीp
प्रोटोकॉल है। अब मैं नीचे की तरफ आऊंगा
यहां पे। तो ये एसटीडी प्रोटोकॉल है। अब
यहां पे आप आएंगे यहां पे अ नीचे की तरफ
यहां पे आएंगे तो यहां पे एक्सटेंसिबल
मार्कअप लैंग्वेज लिखा हुआ है। यहां पे एक
एक्सटेंसिबल मार्केट मार्क मार्कअप
लैंग्वेज का यूज़ हुआ है। तो ये आपका आंसर
हो जाएगा कि एक्स एक्स अ एक्सटेंसिबल
मार्कअप लैंग्वेज का यूज़ हुआ है। तो यहां
पे आप लिख सकते हैं एक्सटेंसिबल मार्केट
लैंग्वेज। एक्सटेंसिबल
मार्कअप लैंग्वेज यही यूज़ हुआ है। तो इस
तरीके से आपको चीजों को करनी है।
राइट? इस तरीके से आपको देखना है। व्हाट
इज़ द अराइवल डेट ऑफ़ द पैकेट? मतलब पैकेट
का अराइवल डेट क्या है? ये सब चीज़ व्हाट
इज़ द टीटीएल वैल्यू? ये सब आपको यहां पे
मिल जाएगी। मतलब एव्री डिटेल्स इज़ एंबेडेड
इन दीज़ सेक्शंस। यहां पे टीटीएल वैल्यू
वगैरह क्या है? किस तरीके से? अब जैसे मान
लो ये फ्रेम है तो फ्रेम की पूरी डिटेल्स
यहां पे आपको फ्रेम की यहां पे डिटेल आपको
मिलेगी। जो भी डेटा है उसके बारे में सारी
डिटेल्स वगैरह जो है वो मिल जाएगी। इथरनेट
में आप आएंगे यहां पे तो आपको इथरनेट
डिटेल्स जो है वो सारी आईपी के आएंगे अंदर
तो आईपी अंदर आईपी की डिटेल्स जिसमें
डिटेल वैल्यू भी आपको मिलता है तो यहां पे
टाइम टू 47 आपको मिल जा रहा है तो आप 47
ले यही होगा शायद मैं अभी उतना वो नहीं कर
रहा हूं सब सारे लैब सॉल्व नहीं कर रहा
हूं मैं आपके लिए वो करके एंड ये उसी
तरीके से मतलब आपको सारी डिटेल्स जो भी
चीजें हैं ना वो मिल जाएंगी ठीक है उसी
तरीके से जैसे फ्रेम है फ्रेम में सारी
डिटेल्स होती हैं लाइक कि क्या अराइवल
टाइम है किस तरीके से है तो वो यहां पे
दिख रहा है कि मे 2004 कुछ इस तरीके से तो
इस तरीके से आप मेह तो मंथ है तो मे पहला
है मंथ आपको देना है तो मे है
तो फाइव ऐसे कर देते हैं फाइव देन 13 कर
देते हैं अ
13 2004 है 2004 ही है शायद 2004 है तो ये
अराइवल टाइम मैंने पैकेट की डिटेल्स वगैरह
जो है वो सारी देता है। तो ये सारी चीज़
यहां पे आपको हो जाएगी। व्हाट इज़ द TCP
पेलोड साइज़? तो अब यह TCP के अंदर ही होगा
भाई। TCP का जो डिटेल होगा उसके अंदर में
होगा। TCP वाली फ्रेम में होगा। तो यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं कि TCP का किस में
होगा? ट्रांसमिशन कंट्रोल प्रो में
ट्रांसमिशन कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल जो है इसमें
से सारी चीज़ होंगी। तो इसमें TCP सेगमेंट
साइज़ जो है यहां पे दिया हुआ है। तो यहां
पे क्या है? TCP पेलोड साइज़ यहां पे बोल
रहा है यहां पे। तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां
पे एक सारी डिटेल्स वगैरह दे रही हैं।
सारी चीजें यहां पे दे रही है। यहां पे तो
से TCB पेलोड यहां पे ये रहा TCB पेलोड
कितने साइज का है ये 424 बाइट्स का है तो
424 बाइट्स यहां पे पेलोड साइज 424 बाइट्स
यहां पे लिख देंगे एंटर हो जाएगा तो उतने
बाइट्स का है। ठीक है? उसी तरीके से व्हाट
इज़ द ई टैग वैल्यू? तो अब ई टैग वैल्यू
भैया रिस्पांस में अ ये इंटरेस्टिंग चीज़
है यहां पे ई टैग वैल्यू। तो यहां पे हम
अगर इसको एक्सपेंड करें तो हम यहां पे अं
हां हाइपर टेक्स्ट ये एचटीटीपी हेडर की
बात करते हैं तो एचटीटीपी हेडर में ई टैग
वैल्यू आती है जो एचटीटीपी हेडर्स होते
हैं उसमें ई टैग वैल्यू होता है तो
एचटीटीपी हेडर किया ई टैग वैल्यू यहां पे
आपको देखने को मिल गई तो ये ई टैग वैल्यू
है यहां पे आप इसको कॉपी कर लीजिए वैल्यू
कॉपी कर लीजिए अगर वैल्यू आ गई तो ओनली
वैल्यू आई है क्या देख लेते हैं एक बार
हां ये आ गई है। तो
ये वैल्यू हमने कॉपी किया। यहां पे हमने
वैल्यू डाल दिया। इस तरीके से आप सॉल्व कर
सकते हैं। ये कोई बहुत बड़ी चीज़ नहीं है।
लैब को सॉल्व करना और ये सब चीज़ बहुत इजी
है ये चीज़। इट्स काफी इजी। बट आपको पैकेट
को रीड करना है। पैकेट को समझना आना
चाहिए। लेट्स से इसको मैं थोड़ा सा बड़ा कर।
हर पैकेट पे जिस पे आप क्लिक करेंगे उसकी
यहां पे पूरी ओएसआई लेयर के अकॉर्डिंग जो
है सारी डिटेल्स आ जाती हैं। और उसके अंदर
में आप अलग-अलग डिटेल्स देख सकते हैं।
WhatsApp के अंदर में। ये एक इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज होती है। अब इसमें गाइस मैं आपको अ
नेक्स्ट जो सेशन होंगी ये तो मैंने आपको
ओवरव्यू दिया है अभी वारशार्क का। वशार का
भी इन डेप्थ जो है एक बचा हुआ है वो उसको
हम कवर करेंगे। इन डेप्थ क्लास एक बचा हुआ
है। उसके बाद वारश कंप्लीट हो जाएगा। ये
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। ठीक है? हां। यहां पे
निशा चौधरी ने पूछा है व्हाट इज़ ई टैग?
देखिए मैं आपको इसलिए बोलता हूं जो भी
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स का कंटेंट होता है व्हाटएवर
कंटेंट डिफ़्रॉनिक्स इज़ प्रोवाइडिंग। मैं
मानता हूं कि अगर आप एक अ एक लाइक एक ऐसे
कैंडिडेट हैं जो लाइक बहुत ही सीरियस है।
ठीक है? तो हर एक वीडियो को फॉलो कीजिए।
मैंने ई टैग हो गया या जो भी
लाइक लाइक व्हाटएवर
वीडियोस आर जो अराइव ऑन डेफन चैनल मैं आई
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू गो थ्रू ऑल दोस
क्योंकि हर में कुछ ना कुछ आपको डिटेल
मिलेगी जो आगे आपको काम आएगी लाइफ में
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में अगर जाना है तो
मैंने एचटीपी की वीडियो जब डाली थी याद
होगा आपको एचटीटीp की वीडियो जिन्होंने भी
देखा होगा एचटीटीp के ऊपर मैंने एक वीडियो
बनाई थी क्लास ली थी बग बाउंट में शायद ली
थी या ऐसे भी ऐसे भी था http के ऊपर राइट
अ मैं यहां पे चलता हूं
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
एंड सर्च करते हैं एचtटीp
हम
हां http हेडर्स ये वाली जो क्लास ली थी
मैंने बग बॉटी की इसमें मैंने पूरा डिटेल
में एचटीपी हेडर्स के बारे में ई टैग ये
सब चीजें ई ई टैग रिस्पांस हेडर होता है
बेसिकली सर्वर असाइन करता है एक यूनिक
वैल्यू असाइन करता है एक पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट को मतलब एक पर्टिकुलर लाइक फाइल
या पेज को जो भी बोल लो वही होता है ई
टैग। अब इसके बारे में डिटेल आपको जानना
है तो आप यह वाली पूरी वीडियो जो है देख
लीजिएगा डे 21 ऑफ़ बग बंटी का ये एचटीटीp
हेडर्स वाला आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। राइट?
यू विल गेट टू अंडरस्टैंड क्या होता है ई
टैग। वैसे Google कर लीजिएगा समझ में आ
जाएगा। हालांकि ओवरव्यू मैंने तो आपको दे
ही दिया है। तो इस तरीके से ये चीजें काम
करती हैं। तो फिलहाल के लिए हमने एक
ओवरव्यू देख लिया है। ओवरव्यू हमने कर
लिया है। फिलहाल के लिए बस मैं इतना ही
करूंगा आज के सेशन में। नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक
एनालाइजर वारशार्क का यह इसका एक और पार्ट
आना बचा हुआ है। प्लीज डू रिमेंबर इट विल
डेफिनेटली कम क्योंकि वार शशार्क बहुत
बड़ी टॉपिक है। मैं उसको दो पार्ट में कवर
करना चाहता था क्योंकि थोड़ा डिटेल डिटेल
में जाना चाहता हूं मैं। तो नेक्स्ट जो
क्लास होगी इसके ऊपर बहुत डिटेल बहुत
अच्छी खासी इन डेप्थ डिटेल क्लास होगी
जिसमें आपको वशार्क का पूरा कच्चा चीटा
समझ में आ जाएगा। एक-एक चीज समझ में आ
जाएगी। इवन आप वायशार्क की जो ये कांसेप्ट
समझ रहे हैं ये आपकी साइबर सिक्योरिटी में
भी हेल्प करेगा और एसओसी में तो खैर उसी
के लिए हम पढ़ रहे हैं तो करेगा ही करेगा।
ठीक है? तो एक जो क्लास है वो होगी। एक
चीज और है
अ
सर इफ यू हैव एन आईडिया लाइक आफ्टर हाउ
मेनी क्लासेस वी कैन बस चारप और क्लासेस
मुश्किल से चारप क्लासेस के बाद आप अप्लाई
करना शुरू कर सकते हैं। चार पांच और
क्लासेस मतलब चार चार पांच ज्यादा से
ज्यादा छह क्लासेस फिर यू कैन स्टार्ट।
ठीक है? दैट्स इट। बस तो इतना ही था आज के
इस सेशन के लिए। एंड मैं इस सेशन को अब
यहां पे एंड करता हूं। इसका नेक्स्ट पार्ट
भी आएगा। याद रखिएगा। मैं पहले ही बोल रहा
हूं। उसको जरूर जरूर देखिएगा। आपका भाष्य
कंप्लीट हो जाएगा। और ये वन ऑफ द बहुत ही
इंपॉर्टेंट क्लास टॉपिक था जो आज मैंने
कराया आपको। ठीक है? तो चलिए। सो बिफोर
एंडिंग द सेशन, लेट्स अगेन गो टू द टॉप
फैंस लिस्ट। यहां पे हमारी टॉप फैंस की
लिस्ट है यहां पे। आप देख सकते हैं दीज़ आर
द टॉप फेंस लिस्ट। थैंक यू वेरी मच। अ मैं
यहां पे पॉप अप कर लेता हूं। इसको ज़ूम कर
लेते हैं।
टॉप फेंस के लिस्ट है ये। सो ये लोग हैं
जो काफी रेगुलर एंड हमेशा अवेलेबल होते
हैं। सो ग्रेट टू सी देम। मोस्ट ऑफ द
कितने लोग हैं जो रिपीटेड हैं। रिपीट
रिपीटेशन वाले हैं जो हमेशा रहते हैं।
रेगुलर वाले हैं। सो अच्छा लगता है आप
लोगों को देख के। गाइस अभी भी आप लोग लगभग
50 लोग हमेशा कंटिन्यू रहते हैं। दैट्स
वेरी वेरी वेरी वेरी नाइस। सो पार्ट टू के
लिए रेडी रहिएगा। इसका पार्ट टू बहुत
अमेजिंग होगा। बहुत ही इन डेप्थ होगा। अभी
तो मैंने ओवरव्यू दिया आपको। बस ओवर ऊपर
ऊपर ऊपर का बताया है भाषा के बारे में।
अभी इन डेप्थ चीजें बतानी बची हुई है। वो
मैं बताऊंगा नेक्स्ट क्लास में। डेफिनेटली
वॉच द नेक्स्ट क्लास। एंड उसके पहले तक ये
यहां तक कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा। नोट्स बना
लीजिएगा। Lindin पे पोस्ट कीजिएगा। की
पॉइंट्स को डिफ्रॉनिस को टैग कीजिएगा। एंड
जब वीडियो दोबारा देखिएगा रिकॉर्डिंग तो
हाइप जरूर कीजिएगा। कमेंट कर दीजिएगा अपना
नाम और की कंप्लीटेड। यह सब काम आप कर
लीजिएगा। आपकी काम है और शेयर कर दीजिएगा।
गा लाइक ठोकने के बाद लाइक ठोकिए
जाते-जाते और शेयर कीजिए उनके बीच जिनको
इन चीजों की नॉलेज की जरूरत है। तो थैंक
यू वेरी मच एवरीबॉडी फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन।
आई होप यू लाइक द सेशन। आई होप यू लर्न
समथिंग। आई होप यू एंजॉयड द सेशन। मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में नेक्स्ट क्लास में
बहुत ही जल्द। तब तक के लिए टाटा बाय-बाय।
गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि एंड सी यू इन द
नेक्स्ट सेशन। थैंक यू वेरी मच।